I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Run your mark, get set, go. Angela, it's a fun run. Wait, I got a car blowed, a bunch of fettuccine, three seconds before I run. Good idea. That's not going to turn on you. Give me the creamy carbs seconds before I take off on a huge adventure. Guys, it is fun run part two. This is the very beginning of season four written by Greg Daniels, directed
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好闺蜜。现在，我们专门为你录制了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是Office ladies。各就各位，预备，跑。安吉拉，这是一场慈善义跑。等等，在我跑步前三秒钟，我汽车爆胎了，还有一堆 fettuccine（意大利面）。好主意。这不会对你不利。在我开始一场大冒险前，给我来点高热量的奶油碳水。伙计们，这是欢乐跑第二部分。这是第四季的开头，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，导演
by Greg Daniels. Let me hitch up with a summary. Last week, Michael hit Meredith with his car breaking her pelvis. And we discovered, though, that Meredith's trip to the hospital may have saved her life since it was revealed she had possibly been exposed to rabies and has now received a vaccine. We also found out that Sprinkles died on Dwight's watch. On Dwight's watch. Well, this week, this week, Michael organizes a fun run to raise money for rabies in honor of Meredith. And we find out what really happened to Sprinkles. Do you see what I'm wearing in honor of this episode? You're wearing your Office, ladies, Sprinkles sweatshirt. I am wearing my Sprinkles sweatshirt. Well, lady, I did not wear anything in honor
由格雷格·丹尼尔斯担任。让我来做个总结。上周，迈克尔开车撞了梅雷迪思，撞碎了她的骨盆。不过我们发现，梅雷迪思去医院可能救了她一命，因为据透露她可能接触过狂犬病，现在已经注射了疫苗。我们还发现小不点（Sprinkles）是在德怀特照看时死的。在德怀特的照看下。好吧，这周，这周，迈克尔为了纪念梅雷迪思，组织了一场欢乐跑来为狂犬病筹集资金。我们还将找出小不点真正遭遇了什么。你们看到我为了致敬这一集穿了什么吗？你穿着你的Office ladies小不点卫衣。我穿着我的小不点卫衣。好吧，女士，我可没有穿任何为了致敬
of Sprinkles. Well, you know what? That tracks for Pam in this episode, because she helps like Angela. Let's see, zero amount, zero amount. Sorry. Okay. She's distracted because in this episode, it's also going to be revealed that Jim and Pam are dating. Listen, one thing I thought of when I watched this episode was, wow, happy Pam is a sassy Pam. She gives zero Fs about what's going on around her. She's a totally different person. Happy sass. Happy sass. Happy Pam sass. Happy Pam sass. Well, let's get into these fast facts. Fast fact number one, you know, this episode is technically the second part of the episode that we broke down last week, right? Because these episodes were an hour long. But if you notice, I feel
小不点的衣服。好吧，你知道吗？这很符合帕姆在这集里的作风，因为她帮了像安吉拉。让我们看看，零，零。抱歉。好吧，她很分心，因为在这集里，吉姆和帕姆在约会的事也要曝光了。听着，我看这一集时想到的第一件事就是，哇，快乐的帕姆是个厚脸皮的帕姆。她对周遭发生的一切完全不在乎。她完全变了个人。快乐厚脸皮。快乐厚脸皮。快乐帕姆的厚脸皮。快乐帕姆的厚脸皮。好吧，让我们进入这些快讯。快讯一，你知道这一集严格来说是我们上周剖析的那集的下集，对吧？因为这两集时长一小时。但如果你注意到，我觉得
like these episodes really stand on their own. They kind of both had their own little plots, right? For sure. Well, I talked to Greg about that, and he told me that Kevin Riley requested four hour long episodes to kick off season four. So the first four episodes of this season are all an hour long. Kevin loved our show. But was there any other reason besides he was like, I want more office? I think it was just that would be a big announcement. In the press, the return of the office four hour long episodes, maybe also they didn't have something for the other time slot. So we were filling two time slots. I'm speculating. I don't know. I like your speculating face and tone. Because my husband does this sometimes
这些集真的很独立。它们俩似乎都有各自的小情节，对吧？确实。好吧，我和格雷格聊过这个，他告诉我凯文·莱利要求用四集一小时的长度来拉开第四季的序幕。所以本季的前四集都是一个小时长的。凯文很喜欢我们的节目。但除了他觉得“我想要更多办公室”之外，还有什么其他原因吗？我觉得可能只是这会是一个大动作。在媒体上，《办公室》回归，四集一小时长，可能也是因为他们另一个时段没有节目排期。所以我们要填补两个时段。我只是在猜测。我不知道。我喜欢你猜测时的表情和语气。因为我丈夫有时也会这样
when he wants to let the kids down easy. Like it's like, Hey, guys, so about those pumpkins that we work on again, they they exploded from the heat. But yeah. Well, I was excited that we got these big super sized episodes that meant that for the supporting cast, some of our storylines would definitely stay in. And that was exciting. Yes. Well, Greg also told me that Kevin Riley told him they're only going to run in this hour long length once at the beginning of the season. Then we're going to have to rerun them later as half hours. And that's really why they stand alone. Greg said it was a challenge because he had to wrap up the first episode in a way that would make it satisfying for a future
当他想让孩子们更容易接受坏消息时。就像是，嘿，伙计们，关于我们一起做的那些南瓜，它们，它们因为太热爆炸了。不过，好吧。好吧，我很高兴我们能有这些超长的大集，这意味着对于配角们来说，我们的一些故事线肯定会保留下来。这让人很兴奋。是的。好吧，格雷格还告诉我，凯文·莱利对他说，这种一小时长的长度在季初只会播一次。然后我们以后得把它们重新剪成半小时的播。这其实就是它们能独立成集的原因。格雷格说这很有挑战性，因为他必须以一种让未来的观众
viewer to watch it in a half hour form. But he couldn't wrap it up too much for the people who were watching it as a one hour episode. He said it was kind of a writing challenge. That sounds like a challenge. I think he did it, though. I think he crushed it. Greg Daniels, you crushed it. Vast fact number two, lady, is a wardrobe breakdown with Carrie Bennett. I love me some Carrie Bennett. Let's hear it. We got so much mail about the wardrobe in this episode, which makes sense because we're seeing everybody out of their office attire, which Carrie said was always a challenge because she had created these office uniforms for people. So anytime we wore our quote unquote street clothes, she was like, who are these
在观看半小时版本时也会觉得满意的方式来收尾第一集。但他又不能为那些作为一小时剧集观看的观众收尾得太彻底。他说这算是一种写作挑战。听起来确实是个挑战。不过我觉得他做到了。我觉得他太棒了。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，你太棒了。快讯二，女士，是与凯莉·贝内特的服装大揭秘。我很喜欢凯莉·贝内特。听听看吧。我们收到了雪片般关于这集服装的邮件，这很合理，因为我们看到大家没有穿办公室制服，凯莉说这总是一个挑战，因为她为每个人设计了这些办公室制服。所以每次我们穿所谓的便服时，她都会想，这些
people in their street clothes? Here's some of the mail we got. Alicia W and Amanda Michenfelder said, did you get to keep your shirts from Fun Run? And Emily Thomas wants to know, did you get to keep a support the rabid wristband? Yeah, I kept both. I kept my shirt and I kept my wristband. I had my wristband for a long time. That's probably somewhere in my scrapbook bin. My t-shirt I did not keep. Carrie kept it in case we ever needed Angela Martin to wear it again because we weren't sure how long this morning process was going to go, you know? Well, we should remind people, Angela, you did not wear one of the famous blue Fun Run t-shirts. You wore a shirt with a picture of sprinkles on it. Yeah. Because people wrote
穿便服的人到底是谁？以下是我们收到的一些邮件。艾莉西亚·W和阿曼达·米琴费尔德问：“你们能保留欢乐跑的衬衫吗？”艾米·托马斯想知道：“你们能留下一条‘支持狂犬病’的腕带吗？”对，我都留了。我留了衬衫，也留了腕带。我的腕带保留了很长时间。那可能在我的剪贴簿箱里的某个地方。我的T恤我没留。凯莉留着它，以防我们什么时候需要安吉拉·马丁再穿一次，因为我们不确定这个哀悼过程会持续多久，你知道的？好吧，我们得提醒大家，安吉拉，你没有穿那件著名的蓝色欢乐跑T恤。你穿了一件印有小不点照片的衬衫。对。因为人们也写信
in about this shirt too, Angela. Molly C and Isaiah Johnson asked, where did Angela's sprinkle shirt come from and did you get to keep it? You said you did not keep it. I did not keep it. And Carrie made that shirt. She had that shirt made. And also when I had my wardrobe fitting for this, Carrie and I talked and Angela would not be in shorts. She would not wear shorts. So that's why I have sort of those little crop pants. And then at first, they had kids for me and I was like, I can't run in kids and I have to actually run. So I need an actual sneaker. There you go. There you go. Well, Carrie told me about those blue shirts, the famous blue shirts with all the writing on them. So she designed those. We
来问这件衬衫的事，安吉拉。莫莉·C和伊赛亚·约翰逊问，安吉拉的小不点衬衫是从哪来的，你留着它了吗？你说你没留。我没留。那件衬衫是凯莉做的。她让人做了那件衬衫。而且当我为此进行服装试穿时，我和凯莉商量过，安吉拉是不会穿短裤的。她绝不穿短裤。这就是为什么我穿的那种有点像七分裤的裤子。然后一开始，他们给我准备了童装，我说，我穿不了童装，我实际上得跑步。所以我需要一双真正的运动鞋。就是这样。就是这样。好吧，凯莉跟我聊了那些蓝衬衫，那些写满字的著名的蓝衬衫。所以那是她设计的。我们
made them ourselves. She said that she just tried to imagine Michael getting on the phone and ordering those t-shirts with the ridiculously long name and insisting that all the words be on the shirt, which I think is a very funny way to approach that design. I mean, I thought it was perfect. And honestly, while we're talking about the shirt, what the heck kind of budget did they have for this? Not only did they have bracelets and those t-shirts, they had flyers and banners. They had a giant Meredith photo poster and a giant check. What was their budget? I mean, we're going to see when we get to that scene in the conference room that we spend quite a bit of our donation money just throwing the fun run. Carrie also
自己做的。她说她只是试着想象迈克尔打电话订购那些印有荒谬长名字的T恤，并坚持要把所有的字都印在衬衫上的情景，我觉得这是一种非常搞笑的设计思路。我的意思是，我觉得完美极了。老实说，我们在聊这件衬衫的时候，他们这集的预算到底是多少啊？他们不仅有手腕带和那些T恤，还有传单和横幅。他们还有一张巨大的梅雷迪思照片海报和一张巨型支票。他们的预算到底是多少？我的意思是，等我们看到会议室的那场戏就会发现，我们把相当一部分的捐款都花在办这个欢乐跑上了。凯莉还
told me that she chose the color blue for the shirts because everybody had to wear it and blue looks good on everyone. She said she always applies the same logic for photo shoots and promo shoots. Blue just looks best. That's right. Well, let's talk about Dwight fan question from Ella Lewis. Why isn't Dwight wearing a fun run shirt? I feel like he would have been the most likely to support Michael's ideas, yet he's wearing a shrewd farm shirt instead. I think it makes perfect sense that he would self advertise. I agree with Ella. I was surprised that Dwight would not just champion Michael the way he does. Carrie told me that she made this shirt. She literally just used a standard stencil and she spray
告诉我，她为衬衫选择蓝色是因为每个人都得穿，而且蓝色对谁都好看。她说她在拍照片和宣传照时总是运用同样的逻辑。蓝色就是最好看的。没错。好吧，我们来聊聊埃拉·刘易斯提出的德怀特粉丝提问。为什么德怀特没穿欢乐跑衬衫？我觉得他是最有可能支持迈克尔想法的人，然而他却穿着一件施鲁特农场（Shrute Farm）的衬衫。我觉得他会自我宣传这太合乎逻辑了。我同意埃拉的看法。我很惊讶德怀特竟然没有像往常那样全力支持迈克尔。凯莉告诉我这件衬衫是她做的。她字面意思上就是用了一个标准模板，在我们开始拍摄前，直接在那个停车场喷漆
painted it in that parking lot right before we started shooting. But after the episode aired, NBC marketing department got so many requests for that shirt that they called her and asked her for her art files so that they could mass produce it and sell it. And Carrie was like, don't have an art file. Have us just have a spray painting thing that I made in the parking lot. If you want to come get my spray paint stencil. Yeah. She was like, um, okay. All right. Well, our final question about the clothing comes from Ian MP and Marina Blank. They're asking, is Michael wearing women's shorts for fun run? Oh man, they're definitely some kind of like biker short with like the little windbreaker short over
喷上去的。但在这集播出后，NBC营销部门收到了太多想要那件衬衫的请求，以至于他们打电话向她索要美术文件，以便批量生产并售卖。而凯莉的反应是：我没有美术文件。只有一个我在停车场弄的喷漆玩意儿。如果你想来拿我的喷漆模板的话。对。她的反应是，呃，好吧。好吧，关于服装的最后一个问题来自伊恩·MP和玛丽娜·布兰克。他们在问，迈克尔在欢乐跑里穿的是女式短裤吗？天哪，那绝对某种类似骑行短裤的东西，外面还套着那种防风的小短裤。对。凯莉说不是。那不是女式短裤。她说史蒂夫的情况是，他其实身材非常好。安吉拉，你和我都知道这一点。他非常非常喜欢健身。
it. Yeah. Carrie says no. They were not women's shorts. She said the thing with Steve was that he's actually really fit. And Angela, you and I know this. He was really, really into fitness. Well, he got into great shape. We've talked about that for 40 year old virgin and then he has just made that part of his lifestyle. And I think in this episode, when he gets in his shorts and his t-shirt, you can see how fit he is. There's no hiding how fit he is. He has like 0% body fat. And it's very clear. Carrie said it was a really a challenge to make him look like Michael anytime he was out of his sort of frumpy Michael suit because he just was in such great shape. She said it was just kind of difficult. So
好吧，他练出了好身材。我们在聊《四十岁的老处男》时就谈过这个，后来他把这变成了生活方式的一部分。我觉得在这集里，当他穿上短裤和T恤时，你能看出他身材有多好。他的好身材根本藏不住。他的体脂率几乎为零。这太明显了。凯莉说，每当他脱掉那种松垮的迈克尔西装时，要让他看起来像迈克尔真的是个挑战，因为他的身材实在太好了。她说这有点困难。所以就是这样。没错。这就是服装大揭秘。我很喜欢。我很喜欢。好吧。快讯三。如你所知，这一集里，吉姆和帕姆没有跑步，很多人在跑，但吉姆和帕姆没有。他们步行。他们去了一个遗产拍卖会。吉姆和帕姆没有跑步，奥斯卡、斯坦利和克里德坐了出租车。但吉姆和帕姆没有跑。他们在后面散步。他们手牵着手。
there you go. Yeah. That is a costume breakdown. I like it. I like it. All right. Fast fact number three. As you know, in this episode, Jim and Pam do not run a lot of people run but Jim and Pam do not. They walk. They go to an estate sale. Jim and Pam don't run and Oscar and Stanley and Creed take a cab. But Jim and Pam do not run. They walk in the back. They hold hands. Well, there was a reason for this. I know. The reason for this is because in May of 2007, we shot this in August. In May, I fell down a set of stairs in New York City and I fractured four bones in my back and I was not allowed to run. So the writers had to write a reason for me to only walk through this episode. That was such a scary
嗯，这其实是有原因的。我知道。原因是在2007年5月，我们在8月份拍摄的这个。在5月，我在纽约的一处楼梯摔倒了，背部的四处骨头骨折了，医生不允许我跑步。所以编剧们必须写一个让我在这集中只能走路的理由。那真是一个可怕的夜晚。我和你在一起。我知道你在。那太可怕了。对，事情是这样的。那是5月，我们在纽约，我们在宣传《办公室》。我们在宣传季终集，他们在一家叫Budakon的俱乐部办了一个盛大的派对，所谓的派对。那是一个工作活动。是的，我们的工作就是和广告商之类的人应酬。我们在工作，但那是高级的工作。
night. I was with you. I know you were. That was so scary. Yeah. So here's what happened. It was May and we were in New York and we were promoting the office. We were promoting the season finale and they threw this big party in quotes party. It was a work event at this club called Budakon. Yeah, it was our job to kind of hobnob with advertisers and stuff. We were at work, but it was a fancy work. Yes. So we're all dressed up and this club is two floors. So you enter on the upper floor. They had this little bar with drinks and they were serving these like pineapple-y daiquiri things and it was sweet and I was like, this seems great. So I grabbed one, but then to get to kind of the main part of the event,
是的，所以我们都盛装打扮，这家俱乐部有两层。所以你从楼上一层进。他们有一个小酒吧提供饮品，他们供应那种菠萝戴吉利酒（daiquiri），甜甜的，我就想，这听起来太棒了。所以我拿了一杯，但为了去到活动的主要区域，你必须走下一段长长的楼梯，那是大理石的，而且很陡。伙计们，它们的坡度真的很陡。对，它们现在还在。这家俱乐部现在还在。所以我走下楼梯。我基本上刚到。我喝了一小口戴吉利酒，然后就出事了。我的脚底一滑，整个人重重地摔在了楼梯边缘。
you had to go down this long set of stairs that were marble and they were steep. You guys, they had a really deep pitch to them. Yeah, they're still there. This club is still there. So I'm walking down these stairs. I've basically just arrived. I've taken one sip of my little daiquiri and something happens. My foot slips out from underneath me and I go crashing down on the edge of these stairs hard to add insult to injury. I also threw my drink in my own face. So that was fun. So I'm sitting on the ground. I'm half covered in daiquiri and I immediately start to feel like I'm going to vomit or everything gets dizzy. And I remember this bouncer comes over and picked me up and he was treating me like
雪上加霜的是，我还把酒泼到了自己脸上。所以这很有趣。于是我坐在地上。我身上半湿着戴吉利酒，我立刻开始觉得想吐，或者一切开始眩晕。我记得有个保安过来把我扶起来，他对待我的方式就像我是那种喝得酩酊大醉的好莱坞小明星。他完全没有表现出关心的样子。就像是，把她弄出去。把这个酒鬼弄走。而我的反应是，我不是，但我当时整个人晕头转向的，你知道吗？所以我记得他们把我带到了储藏室，安吉拉，你也在。我告诉你我感觉很不舒服。我记得你掀起我衬衫的背面说，叫救护车。好吧，我就在你身后的楼梯上，我看到你摔下去了。
I was like a boozy, drunken Hollywood starlet. Like he was in no way regarding me with much care. It was like, get her out of there. Get the boozer out. And I was like, I'm not, but I was all disoriented, you know? So I remember they took me back to the storeroom, Angela, and you were there. And I told you I didn't feel good. And I remember you lifted up the back of my shirt and you said, call an ambulance. Well, I was behind you on that staircase and I saw you go down. It happened in slow motion. Someone had spilt their drink or something on those stairs and they were marble and they were slick and you, you had these wedge shoes on. You turned your ankle and you went down
这一切就像是慢动作。有人把酒洒在了那些楼梯上，大理石很滑，而你，你穿着坡跟鞋。你崴了脚，然后重重地摔了下去。你知道的，当你作为目击者看着某事发生时，你会想，不——就像我不知道该怎么阻止它。一切都在进行中。是的，我永远不会忘记那一晚，因为你的背部，看起来很糟糕。是的，我很害怕。好吧，那之后的事我记不太清了。我不记得坐救护车的经历，但我知道你和我在一起，安杰。我记得在医院里意识模糊，你一直守在我身边，女士。我知道你在。我记得他们给我拍了X光。我记得你告诉我，我病床旁边的那个人被手铐铐在病床上。
so hard. And you know, when you're the person watching something happen, how you're like, nah, like I didn't know how to stop it. It was all in motion. And yeah, I'll never forget that night because your back was, it looked bad. And yeah, I was, I was scared. Well, I don't remember much else after that. I don't remember the ambulance ride, but I know you were with me, Ange. And I remember going in and out at the hospital and you were by my side the whole time, lady. I know you were there. And I remember they x-rayed me. I remember you told me the guy in the bed next to me was handcuffed to his bed. There was a guy in a chair next to your bed and they brought him in. He was real surly
你床旁边的一把椅子上坐着个人，他们把他带了进来。他真的很暴躁，他们把他用手铐铐在椅子上了。然后我把你床周围的小帘子拉上了。哦，天哪。而且，我留下来陪你，我对此非常坚持。你知道，我说，她在这里没有家人。我哪儿也不去。她在异国他乡的急诊室里，她没有家人，老兄，你被我缠上了。所以他们没有找我麻烦。我一直陪你到凌晨四点。我们为你安排了一间病房，然后我们知道了更多细节。一旦把你安顿好，我第二天早上本来应该和雷恩·威尔逊一起上《今日秀》。我们本该接受关于《办公室》的采访，他们有一个关于德怀特和
and they handcuffed him to the chair. And I shut the little curtain around your bed. Oh, dear. And also, I was staying with you and I was really adamant about it. You know, I was like, she has no family here. I am not like going anywhere. She's in an emergency room in a city that's not her own. She has no family and you are stuck with me, buddy. So they, they didn't mess with me. And I stayed with you till four in the morning. We got you a hospital room and we knew more details then. And once we got you set up in your room, I went, I was supposed to be on the Today Show that morning with Rainn Wilson. We were supposed to be interviewed for the office and they had a whole piece about Dwight and
安吉拉的整段节目。我问NBC，你知道的，我说，我一个小时后就得直播了，但我现在和我的朋友在病房里。我不能，我不能去那里。他们说，别担心，我们会通知《今日秀》的。所以几年后，我在白宫记者晚宴上。我坐在NBC《今日秀》的桌子旁，我们在聊天，只是在聊，哦，我们上次见你是什么时候？他们说，你本来应该和雷恩·威尔逊一起上《今日秀》的。你放了鸽子。我说，什么？我才没放鸽子。我和珍娜在医院里。他们没告诉你吗？他们从来没告诉过他们。他们从来没告诉过他们你为什么没出现。他们只是以为你是个不靠谱的演员。
Angela. And I asked NBC, you know, I was like, I'm supposed to be on the air in an hour, but I'm in a hospital room with my friend. I can't, I can't be there. And they said, worry, we'll let the Today Show know. So years later, I'm at the White House Correspondents Dinner. I'm sitting at the NBC Today Show table and we talk about, we're just talking about, oh, when was the last time we saw you? And they were like, you were supposed to do the Today Show with Rainn Wilson. You were in no show. And I was like, what? I wasn't in a no show. I was with Jenna in a hospital. Didn't they tell you that? They never told them. They never told them why you didn't show up. They just thought you were like a
那一晚在这个保安眼里给我打上了“喝醉的女演员”的烙印。然后第二天《今日秀》觉得你是个不靠谱的人。而我们的反应是，不，悲剧，悲剧发生了。是的。后来我上过《今日秀》，但我想：他们到底觉得我没出现多少年？天哪。好吧，你知道，我永远不会忘记医生走进来时说的好消息是你要重新走路了。哦，天哪。我的反应是，那是，我的意思是，这确实是好消息，但这听起来接下来会有很多坏消息。结果证明，我背部的横突有四处骨折。如果你非要受背部伤的话，我想这是最好的情况，因为它们会像断肋骨一样自行愈合。
flaky actress. This night branded me in this bouncer's eyes as some boozed up actress. And then the Today Show, the next day, thought you were a flake. And we were like, no tragedy, tragedy happened. Yeah. And I've done the Today Show now since, but I was like, how many years did they just think I didn't show up? Oh my gosh. Well, you know, I'll never forget the doctor coming in and he said, the good news is you're going to walk again. Oh my God. And I was like, that's, I mean, that is good news, but that sounds like there's a lot of bad news coming. So as it turns out, I had fractured four of the transverse vertebrae in my back. If you're going to have a back injury, I guess this is the best one because
而且多活动是最好的治疗方式。所以尽管走路和移动对我很困难，但我还是被鼓励去动。这里有个疯狂的故事转折。你知道，NBC让我们在丽思卡尔顿酒店住了两天，因为我们要进行媒体宣传。他们和酒店有合作，整个剧组都住在丽思卡尔顿。还记得吗，女士，我们要求住连通房，我们兴奋极了。真可以说是“乡下老鼠进城”。我们住在面向中央公园的丽思卡尔顿，整整两晚。我们太兴奋了。好吧，我不能回家。我不能离开。所以NBC不得不付钱让我在丽思卡尔顿住了两周。你猜怎么着？什么？
they heal on their own, similar to a broken rib. And motion is the best thing for you. So even though walking and moving was really difficult for me, I was encouraged to do it. Here's a crazy twist to the story. You know, NBC had put us up at the Ritz Carlton for these two days that we were going to do press. They had a deal with the hotel and the entire cast was put up at the Ritz Carlton. And remember, lady, we asked for adjoining rooms and we were so excited. Talk about country mouse come to town. We're at the Ritz Facing Central Park two whole nights. We were so excited. Well, I couldn't go home. I couldn't leave. So NBC had to pay for me to live at the Ritz Carlton for two weeks. And guess what? What?
第一周，我和你待在一起。我知道你没离开我身边。我没有离开你因为你的家人在赶来的路上，但，你知道的，他们需要几天才能到。所以我一直都在。我只记得那段时光。而且，你知道，我觉得每段友谊都有这样具有里程碑意义的时刻，让你们永远紧密相连。我们当然也有过几次，正在听节目录音的好朋友们，你们懂这种时刻。这就是其中之一，当你帮你的朋友上厕所时。是的。珍娜，你在我剖腹产后也这么做过。你帮了我。就像，我记得这个。这些是，这就是那些闺蜜时刻。我们都曾在对方身上经历过插导尿管的时刻。
For the first week, I was with you the whole time. I know you didn't leave my side. I didn't leave your side because you had family on the way, but, you know, they needed a few days to get there. And so I was there. And I just remember that time. And, you know, I think every friendship has these milestone moments that you're forever bonded by. And we've certainly had a few and best friends listening to this out there. You know those moments. This was one of those moments when you're helping your friend get on the toilet. Yep. And Jenna, you did this for me after my C-section. You helped me. Like, I remember this. These were, this was one of those BFF moments. We have both been with the other
对。你需要你的朋友出去一下，等我插这个导尿管吗？不用。不，我其实更愿意握着她的手，求你了。我希望有人陪着我。对啊。所以任何在听的朋友，如果你想知道为什么我和安吉拉是好闺蜜，而且会永远是好闺蜜，一起插过导尿管的朋友才会永远在一起。好吧。哦，天哪。哦，我这个故事的最后一部分很简单，就是我有好几天不能洗头，我的头发太臭了。我很抱歉你得忍受这个，安琪。那个菠萝味，真的变得超恶心。我确实弄湿了一块毛巾，试图用湿毛巾帮你把头发弄湿。你确实这么做了。你做了。不过不管怎样，
while one has had a catheter. Yeah. Do you need your friend to step out while I give you this catheter? Nah. No, I actually prefer to hold her hand, please. I'd, I'd like someone here with me. Yeah. So anybody out there, if you're wondering why Angela and I are best friends and will be best friends forever, friends who catheter together stay together. All right. Oh man. Oh, my final piece of this story is simply that I couldn't shower for several days and my hair was so smelly. I'm sorry you had to live with that, Ang. That pineapple, it really turned real gross. And I did wet, I did wet a wash rag and tried to dampen your hair with the wash rag. You did. You did. But anyway,
伙计们，这就是为什么帕姆在这集中不跑步的原因。我已经康复了，但我觉得那时候我还不能自己开车，而且医生不允许我跑步。你的医生给你制定了非常具体的康复计划，因为背部的伤可开不得玩笑。你绝对不能马虎。但我现在完全康复了。没有问题。没有，没有任何后遗症。嗯，我很喜欢吉姆和帕姆的故事线。我觉得这让他们看起来非常甜蜜。就像他们只是打算到处逛逛。他们不打算参与。然后他们有了一场如此美妙的散步，还能手牵手，我觉得效果太棒了。行得通。行得通。好吧，伙计们，谢谢你们听我们一起回忆过去。我们休息一下，马上
guys, that's why Pam doesn't run in this episode. I was healed, but I don't think at this point I was driving myself yet and I wasn't allowed to run. Your doctor had you on a very specific sort of recovery plan because you do not mess with the back. You don't mess around. But I'm fully healed now. No problems. No, no residual problems. Well, I loved the storyline for Jim and Pam. I thought it made it just really sweet. Like they just, they were just going to hang out. They weren't going to participate. And then they had this sort of lovely walk and they got to hold hands and I thought it worked out great. It worked. It worked. Well, guys, thanks for listening to us go down that memory lane. We'll take a break and we'll
回来深入剖析这一集。好的，我们回来了。这一集开场是帕姆接电话。“迈克尔·斯科特旗下的邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司梅雷迪思·帕尔默纪念名人狂犬病意识欢乐跑治愈大赛。”但其实，你知道的，这就是职业业余配对治愈赛。我最喜欢那个时刻的一点是你的语气。他们挂了电话。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我们收到了加布里埃尔·B、弗兰克·S、卡洛斯·D、阿尔伯托·R和卡米尔·Y关于这点的粉丝提问。珍娜，你必须背下欢乐跑治愈大赛那个长长的名字，还是每次说的时候都是看纸条的？不，伙计们，我必须背下来。但我确实把它写在一张纸上放在我面前。
be back to a really dive into this episode. Okay, we are back. This episode opens with Pam answering the phone. Michael Scott's Dunder Mifflin Scranton Meredith Palmer Memorial Celebrity Rabies Awareness Fun Run Race for the Cure. But it's, you know, it's the pro am race for the cure. My favorite thing about that whole moment was how you delivered. They hung up. It's so good. It's so good. Well, we got some fan questions about this from Gabriel B. Frank S. Kalos D. Alberto R. And Camille Y. Jenna, did you have to memorize that long title for the fun run race for the cure or did you look at a piece of paper every time you said it? No, you guys, I had to memorize that. But I did have it sitting on a piece
就像我会全神贯注地看着它，因为那真的是一大串绕口令。要说出来真的太不容易了。但我为了那场戏确实把它背下来了。而且这是一个毫无逻辑的长串。对我来说，如果有逻辑的话我能记住。我的大脑会帮我把它们拼凑起来。但如果它只是一个清单，你就得下功夫去记了。是的，那样更难。肯定的。就像我，我绝不可能成为《急诊室的故事》或那种剧里的医生，比如《实习医生格蕾》里那种他们跑过走廊，担架上推着个人，然后喊着：“我们需要三袋血压用药，把缝合线拿来。”我每次看这些剧时都会这么想，总是这样。
of paper in front of me. Like I would look at it intensely because that is a mouthful. That is a lot to have to say. But I did memorize it for that scene. And it's a mouthful that doesn't make sense. Like for me, I can memorize something if it makes sense. My brain will piece it together for me. But if it's just like a list, you have to work at it. Yeah, that is more difficult. For sure. Like I there's no way I could have ever been one of those doctors on ER or whatever, like on Grey's Anatomy where they're running down the hallway and they got someone on the stretcher and they're like, we need three BP use and get the suture sewed up. I think that all the time when I watched those shows all the time,
我觉得他们只是在大喊大叫一些行话。他们根本不知道自己在说什么。是的。是的。好吧，然后迈克尔有一个我非常喜欢的精彩单人访谈，他在访谈中让我们知道，一个女人不应该非得被车撞才能明白自己得了狂犬病。但事实就是如此。好吧，你知道吗，迈克尔再次站出来为女性而战了。是的，完全正确。然后我们走到办公区。镜头环顾四周。大家都在打电话，就像电话拉票一样，试图为这个事业募集捐款。他让整个办公室的人都这么做。真难以置信我们当中居然有人能在这一天之后还保住工作。我喜欢他走过来时说：“嗨，斯坦利。”迈克尔什么时候才能吸取教训，你不能对斯坦利开这种无聊玩笑？斯坦利才不吃你那一套。他才不呢。
I think like they're just yelling out jargon. They have no idea what they're saying. Yes. Yeah. Well, then Michael has an amazing talking head that I really love where he lets us know that a woman should not have to be hit by a car to learn that she has rapes. But here we are. Well, you know what, Michael is there fighting for women once again. Yes, exactly. Well then we go out into the bullpen. We're panning around. People are, I guess on the phones kind of phone banking trying to get donations for this cause. He has the whole office doing this. It's unbelievable that any of us had a job after this day. And I love that he walked up and said, hi, Stankley. Like when is Michael going to learn you can't
斯坦利是一个对无聊玩笑免疫的人。是的，别把你的玩笑带到斯坦利这儿来。好吧，菲yllis正在狂犬病被子上埋头苦干。她把它举了起来。这家公司到底有多少条被子？我的意思是，我觉得这是在致敬安全培训里的抑郁症被子。他当时还纳闷，就像是，我们应该做一条抑郁症被子吗？而迈克尔说，不，没时间缝被子了。因为显然这成了一个梗。这成了一个梗。让菲yllis来做。好吧，我们收到了玛丽·哈尔西的粉丝提问。谁制作了狂犬病被子？好吧，伙计们，那是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。我的意思是，不是他亲手制作的，但他得找人做出那些方块来。
do bits with Stanley? Stanley doesn't want your bits. He doesn't. He is Stanley is a bit free person. Yeah, don't bring your bits to Stanley. Well, Phyllis is hard at work on the rabies quilt. She holds it up. How many quilts does this company make? I mean, I felt like this was a callback to the depression quilt from safety training. And he wondered why it was like, should we do a depression quilt? And Michael's like, no, no time to sew the quilt. Cause clearly it's a thing. It's a thing. Put Phyllis on it. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Halsey. Who made the rabies quilt? Well, guys, it was Phil Shea. I mean, he didn't personally make it, but he had to get someone to make those squares.
如果你想买的话，网上有全尺寸的被子。直接谷歌搜索一下。开玩笑吧。狂犬病被子 办公室。人们真的在做这个。你可以买到。我一定要去谷歌搜一下。我想看看。你知道我妈妈是个拼布爱好者，对吧？是的，安吉拉。我在今天的笔记里，直接写了“安吉拉，你妈妈会做拼布”。我有好几件你妈妈做的拼布作品。我妈妈是老派的那种拼布匠，你知道的，不用机器。她把所有的碎片都剪下来，然后自己做图案。她会把家里的一间卧室腾出来做这个。然后她把所有东西都亲手缝起来。有时她会用机器缝背面，但她很多年前在宾夕法尼亚州
And if you want to buy it, there is a full size version of the quilt online. Just Google it. Get out. Rabies quilt the office. People are making them. You can buy them. I have got to Google that. I want to see it. You know, my mom's a quilter, you know? Yes, Angela. In my notes for today, I literally wrote Angela, your mom quilts. I have several pieces of your mom's quilting. My mom is old school type of quilter where, you know, no machine. She cuts out all the pieces and then she like makes her, her pattern. She'll use like one of the bedrooms in the house. And then she sews that all by hand. And she'll do the backing sometimes, you know, with the machine, but she actually purchased in Pennsylvania years
从一个阿米什家庭买了一个木制的拼布架，上面的每一个钉子，每一样东西都是木头的。没有任何金属螺丝之类的东西。她把拼布面放在上面然后进行缝制。我觉得每一件都是艺术品。既然我们在聊拼布，我想提一下我非常喜欢的一位艺术家，比萨·巴特勒（Bisa Butler）。她制作这种巨大的、真人大小的拼布肖像，我简直有点着迷了。去她的Instagram页面看看。用户名是@Bisa Butler。它们看起来像画，但其实不是。我马上就要去看了。好的。快看。天哪。太美了。是的。我太喜欢她的作品了，女士。我太喜欢了。
and years ago from an Amish family, a wooden quilt rack, and every peg, everything is wooden. There's no metal screws or anything. And she puts her quilt top on there and quilts. And I feel like every single one is a piece of art. Since we're talking about quilting, I want to bring up this artist that I love, Bisa Butler. She makes these huge life size quilted portraits that I'm slightly obsessed with. Go to her Instagram page. It's at Bisa Butler. They look like paintings, but they're not. I'm going to look at it right now. Okay. Look at it. Oh my gosh. They're beautiful. Yeah. I just love her work, lady. I love it. I can't wait to see it in person one day. It's beautiful. It's art. It's gorgeous.
我等不及有一天能亲眼看到它了。太美了。这是艺术。太华丽了。她还在《纽约时报》上被报道过。她有这个。我的意思是，她到处都是。她是个大人物，去看看吧。Instagram上的Bisa Butler。好吧，你知道的，我们接下来要转到一个安迪关于乳头擦伤的单人访谈。但你注意到安迪现在坐在凯伦的座位上了吗？我注意到了。而且我们上周没提到这点，当凯伦清理工位时，她把公司的电话和电脑也拿走了吗？就像，我不知道，所有东西都没了。全都没了。全都没了。是的。好吧，我们收到了一条关于安迪乳头擦伤的粉丝提问，来自林赛·L，她说：“乳头擦伤这个主意是谁想出来的？是根据个人经历改编的吗？”好吧，格雷格告诉我这是
And she was featured in the New York Times as well. She had this. I mean, she's all over the place. She's a big deal, but check it out. Bisa Butler on Instagram. Well, you know, we're about to move on to an Andy talking head here about nipple chafing. But did you notice Andy is now sitting at Karen's desk? I did. And also we didn't mention this last week, but when Karen cleared out, did she take the company phone and the computer? Like, I don't, everything was gone. Everything. It was all gone. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question about Andy's nipple chafing from Lindsay L who said, who came up with the nipple chafing idea? Was it based off of a personal experience? Well, Greg told me that this was
贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）的主意。所以我问了他这件事。他说，是的，这就是他的主意。他曾经在芝加哥马拉松赛终点给完赛的奔跑者发放水和毛毯。他简直不敢相信有多少男性跑者冲过终点线时，衬衫乳头部位有血迹，那是乳头擦伤造成的。他说这简直震惊了他，让他挥之不去。他一直对这个耿耿于怀。最后他终于把它写进了一集里。所以我觉得这对他来说非常具有治愈效果。能够把这段经历转化为艺术，这真的很厉害。好吧，这确实是个真事。我当然也查过了。珍娜，这也被称为“跑者乳头”。哦，我根本不知道这居然是个常见现象。而且在冬天更常见，
an idea from Justin Spitzer. So I asked him about it. And he said, yes, this was his idea. And that he had once handed out waters and blankets to runners who were finishing the Chicago marathon. And he could not believe how many men were crossing the finish line with blotches of blood on their shirts over their nipples from nipple chafing. He said it sort of, it shocked him and haunted him. And he had been obsessed with it ever since. And he was finally able to write it into an episode. So I think this was very healing for him. It's a real able to take this experience and turn it into art. Well, it's a real thing. And of course I looked it up. Jenna, it's also called joggers nipple. Oh, I had no idea
因为冬天乳头容易勃起。但有很多方法可以预防。其中一种就是像这样把它们遮盖起来。有各种各样的公司生产这种产品。现在还有女性用的乳头贴，比如当你不想让乳头在衣服里显露出来的时候，你知道的，我们做服装试穿时有时他们会说：“哦，我们可能需要在那里贴点东西。”男性其实也有一个完全不同的产业。你知道的，我喜欢好名字，珍娜，特别是给公司起名字。我太喜欢了。所以我也找到了一些名字，比如：Nip Ease、Mr. Nip、Nip Strips。哇。好吧，我猜，我想，因为男性的胸毛比较多。就像
it was such a thing. And it's more common in the winter, because nipples are erect then. But there's many ways to prevent it. And one of them is sort of like covering them like this. And there are all kinds of companies that make these. And now there's nipple covers for women, like when you don't want your nipples to show in clothing, you know, we've had wardrobe fittings where sometimes they're like, Oh, we might need to put something there. There's a whole other industry for men. And you know, I love, I love a good name, Jenna, for businesses. I love it. So we've got a few that I found were Nip Ease, Mr. Nip, Nip Strips. Wow. Well, I imagine, I guess, because men have harrier chests. Like what
我注意到当埃德在遮挡他的乳头时，我一直在想，当他试图把它撕下来时会发生什么？因为胸毛吗？如果我是个男的话，这些公司会为我解决这个问题吗？我不知道。我不知道。Mr. Nip，那是其中之一吗？Mr. Nip、Nip Strips、Nip Ease。也许是Nip Strips吧。好吧，我记得和埃德聊过关于他不得不用的那种胶带和棉球的事，他说这真的很不舒服。对他的来说，这一集可一点都不舒服。我毫不怀疑。我毫不怀疑。好吧，女士，现在安迪要告诉安吉拉，对于她的猫去世他感到非常抱歉。这可能正引导她走向安迪。
I noticed when Ed was like, covering his nipples was, I just kept thinking, what happens when he tries to take that off? Because of the hair? Will these companies solve that problem for me, I guess, if I'm a man? I don't know. I don't know. Mr. Nip, was that one of them? Mr. Nip and Nip Strips, Nip Ease. Maybe the Nip Strips. Well, I remember talking to Ed about like those, that tape and cotton ball thing that he had to do. And he said it was really uncomfortable. This was not a comfortable episode for him. I don't doubt it. I don't doubt it. Well, Lady Now, Andy is going to tell Angela how very sorry he is that her cat passed away. This might be leading her maybe toward Andy.
是的，你知道，有一个被删减的片段，德怀特和安吉拉在发即时消息，德怀特试图弥补，而安吉拉根本不理他。她越来越厌烦，然后她回头看了看德怀特，而安迪正好坐在德怀特身后，他还以为安吉拉在看他。哦，所以我觉得他们在这里埋下了小伏笔。好吧，现在有一个安吉拉的单人访谈，你在哭，你谈到小不点是你的好闺蜜，你还在分享小不点的照片，因为你包括了一张万圣节时的照片。是的，你们就像是一对在城里闲逛的小猫咪。一对在城里闲逛的小猫咪。好吧，女士，我们收到了一些关于这方面的信件。
Yeah, you know, there's a deleted scene where Dwight and Angela are exchanging instant messages and Dwight's trying to make amends and Angela's not having it. She's getting fed up and she looks over her shoulder towards Dwight and Andy is directly behind him and he thinks Angela is looking at him. Oh, so I think they're planting little seeds here. Well now you have a talking head, Angela, where you are crying and you're talking about how Sprinkles was your best friend and you're sharing pictures of Sprinkles because you're including one from the last Halloween. Yeah. Where you're just a couple of kittens out on the town. A couple of kittens out on the town. Well, Lady, we got some mail about this.
是的，关于这些照片。是的，来自凯特·西伯、曼迪·帕斯卡尔和安妮-玛丽·莫里森：“你们是必须去拍写真，还是他们只是把猫P到了你的怀里？”我做了两件事。如果你注意的话，有几张照片，特别是有一张野餐毯的。我躺在野餐毯上。旁边有一碗葡萄，我抱着那只猫。如果你注意的话，我穿着我在《海滩游戏》（Beach Games）里的衣服。哦，对。对吧？所以有几张照片我穿着《海滩游戏》的衣服。好吧，菲尔·谢伊把我拉到一边说：“安吉拉，接下来的一集我们需要一些你和弹力豆（Sprinkles）在一起的照片。”所以我们在停车场准备坐大巴去拍《海滩游戏》的那天，
Yes, about the photos. Yes, from Kate Sieber, Mandy Pascal and Anne-Marie Morrison. Did you have to do a photo shoot or did they just photoshop a cat into your arms? I did a little bit of both. So if you'll notice a few of the photos, like in particular, there's the picnic blanket one. I'm laying on a picnic blanket. There's a bowl of grapes and I'm holding the cat. If you notice, I am wearing my outfit from Beach Games. Oh, yeah. Right? So there's a few photos of me in my Beach Games outfit. Well, Phil Shea pulled me aside and was like, Angela, we're going to need some photos of you with Sprinkles for an upcoming episode. So that day where we started out for Beach Games on the bus in the parking
菲尔·谢伊就说：“安吉拉，我一有机会就把你抓过来，我们快快拍完这些。”好吧。所以在我们开始拍《海滩游戏》的那天，在我们去海滩之前，你知道的，当我们还在离开邓德米夫林的时候，我偷偷溜去找菲尔·谢伊，我们拍了好多那种照片，我穿着我自己的夹脚拖鞋走过去，你能在照片里看到。这就是为什么我光着脚。不是很奇怪吗？安吉拉·马丁怎么会光着脚还穿着一双夹脚拖鞋，你甚至能看到拖鞋上的小老鹰标志，因为那是American Eagle的。那是我的American Eagle夹脚拖鞋。这太不可思议了。好吧，我太喜欢你在这段单人访谈里的表现了。你整集都表现得太棒了，安琪。哦，谢谢。
lot, Phil Shea just said, Angela, I'm going to grab you when I can and we'll just quickly take these. Okay. So the day that we started Beach Games, before we went to the beach, you know, when we were still leaving Dunder Mifflin, I snuck off with Phil Shea and we took a bunch of those and I walked over in my own flip flops and you can see them in the photo. That's why I'm barefoot. Isn't that weird? That Angela Martin would be barefoot with a pair of flip flops and you can see a little eagle on the flip flops because they're American eagle. They're my American eagle flip flops. That is incredible. Well, I loved you in this talking head so much. You're so good in this whole episode, Anne. Oh, thanks.
太感谢了。好吧，接下来，珍娜，我们有这场戏。开始于24.02，我把这场戏命名为“剧组对我们粉转黑的时刻”。萨姆，你能播放这个吗？我有感情问题，既然你总是有感情问题，我想你一定能给我一些建议。怎么了？我有一个疯狂的想法，虽然我知道这很疯狂，也许德怀特杀了我的猫。我回家时，小不点的尸体在冷冻柜里，也就是德怀特说他放她的地方。但我所有的冷冻法式薯条袋子都被抓成了碎屑。有什么不对劲。兽医正在做尸检。安吉拉，我很抱歉。罗伊以前杀过你的猫吗？我其实更喜欢狗。嗯，珍娜，你还记得我们拍那场戏的情节吗？
Thanks so much. Well, up next, Jenna, we have the scene. It starts at 24.02 and I titled this scene the moment the crew turned on us. Sam, can you play this? I'm having relationship problems and since you're always having relationship problems, I thought you'd be able to give me some advice. What's wrong? I have this crazy thought that I know is crazy that maybe Dwight killed my cat. When I got home, Sprinkle's body was in the freezer where Dwight said he left her. But all my bags of frozen French fries had been clogged to shreds. Something's not right. The vet's doing an autopsy. Angela, I'm sorry. Did Roy ever kill one of your cats? I'm more of a dog person. Um, Jenna, do you remember us doing that scene?
记得。我们得给大家好好剖析一下，因为导演 literally（字面意思）走过来直接说：“我得现在就把你们俩叫停。”那是格雷格。我知道。我知道。所以当时我得从隔断板上面探出头来，我刚说了句“然后你——”你就把我逗笑了。我直接破功了。光是看你的脑袋从隔断板上面冒出来，我就开始大笑。一个字都还没说出口呢。而且每一次你一开始笑，我就会跟着笑。有时候我好不容易调整好状态，从隔断板后面探出头，而你已经在大笑了。是的。因为我知道接下来要发生什么，我懂。安吉拉，你得从我的角度想象一下，看到你那个小金发脑袋突然冒出来是什么感觉。
Yes. We got to break it down for people because literally the director came over and was like, I'm just going to stop you right now. It was Greg. I know. I know. So I had to pop up over the partition and I start off with like, and then you got me right there. I was done. I just started laughing just from your head popping over the partition started laughing. No words have come out yet. And every single time you started laughing, then I would start laughing. And then there were times I would get it together and I'd come up over the partition and you'd already be laughing. Yeah. Because I knew what was, I knew. Angela, you have to imagine from my point of view what it's like to have your tiny blonde head pop up suddenly.
这太搞笑了。我们还应该提一下，这场戏原本排在午饭前拍摄。是的。而且每个人都饿坏了。你总是在午饭前特别饿，因为你早上五点、六点就被叫去上班了，但午饭要到一点才吃。所以在12点40分的时候，你处于低血糖愤怒的状态。剧组里的每个人在12点40分时都超级饿。尽管有零食，但你只想坐下来，想要你的30分钟休息时间，想要吃一顿热乎的饭。而这里却有两个女演员连一句台词都说不完整。这两个女孩笑得太厉害连话都说不出来了。格雷格就说：“要不我们休息一下吧？要不给你们俩一分钟时间调整一下？”我说：“哦不，珍娜，他们——”
It's very funny. And we should also mention this scene was scheduled right before lunch. Yes. And everyone was really hungry. You're always really hungry before lunch because you get called into work at five AM, six AM, but lunch is not until one. So you are hangry at 1240. Everybody on a set is super hangry at 1240. Even though there's snacks, you want to sit down, you want your 30 minute break, you want to eat a hot meal. And here you have these two actresses who cannot even get one line out. These two girls who are literally laughing so hard they can't speak. And Greg was like, why don't we take a break? Why don't we give you guys a minute to get it together? And I said, oh no, Jenna, they're
这非常搞笑。我们还应该提到，这场戏刚好安排在午饭前。是的。每个人都很饿。午饭前你总是很饿，因为你五点、六点就被叫去工作，但午饭要到一点才吃。所以你在十二点四十的时候会气饿交加。片场的每个人在十二点四十时都超级气饿交加。尽管有零食，但你想坐下来，想要你的三十分钟休息时间，想要吃一顿热饭。这里有两位女演员，甚至连一句台词都说不出来。这两个女孩笑得太厉害了，简直说不出话。格雷格说，我们为什么不休息一下？为什么不给你们一分钟时间调整一下？我说，哦不，珍娜，她们
turning on us. And like, I felt so bad because normally when we would break in a scene, the crew was laughing with you. And other actors would laugh too and be like, you guys, no one was laughing. No, it was just us. We were so tickled to have a scene together. We always were. And this was a comedic scene we got to do. This was funny. Yeah. And I'm surprised we even have one take that's usable because we were laughing so hard. And now let's just take a minute to talk about Happy Pam sass because Happy Pam doesn't give Angela anything. She's like, can you imagine Angela finally reaching out to Pam and all she gets is, hmm, well, I'm more of a dog person. Are you flipping kidding me? Well, Angela, what do you
向我们袭来。而且，我感觉太糟糕了，因为通常当我们在片场笑场时，剧组会和你一起笑。其他演员也会笑，然后说，你们这些家伙，当时根本没人笑。不，只有我们。我们能在一起拍一场戏觉得太高兴了。我们一直都这样。而且这是一场我们可以演的喜剧戏。这很有趣。是的。而且我很惊讶我们竟然能有一个镜头是可以用的，因为我们笑得太厉害了。现在让我们花一分钟时间来聊聊“傲娇帕姆”，因为快乐帕姆根本不给安吉拉任何面子。她就像是在说，你能想象安吉拉终于主动联系帕姆，而她得到的却只有，嗯，好吧，我其实更喜欢狗。你在开美国玩笑吗？好吧，安吉拉，你到底
expect anytime Pam has ever tried to comfort or help Angela? Angela just insults her. I think Pam is being self protective. She's having good boundaries in my opinion. She's got good boundaries and she's getting laid. And she didn't have time for anybody anymore. Oh my God. Oh my God. That is private. Well, Angela, I will say this. We have a fan soap box and I think you're gonna like it. Oh, I want to hear it. This is from Amy Wagner, Rivka Wasserman, Kayla Kelly, Kaelin White, and Christina Chadborne. They all wrote in to say this, I hate to break it to you, but Pam is actually responsible for the death of Sprinkles and the breakup of D'Angela. Pam guilt Angela into seeing Meredith at lunch instead of taking care of Sprinkles, which is why Angela
指望什么？每当帕姆试图安慰或帮助安吉拉时？安吉拉总是侮辱她。我觉得帕姆是在自我保护。在我看来，她有很好的界限感。她有很好的界限感，而且她现在性生活很和谐。她再也没时间理任何人了。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。那是隐私。好吧，安吉拉，我得这么说。我们有一个粉丝肥皂箱环节，我想你会喜欢的。哦，我想听听。这是由艾米·瓦格纳、里夫卡·沃瑟曼、凯拉·凯利、凯琳·怀特和克里斯蒂娜·查德伯恩共同写信寄来的。她们都写道：我讨厌打破你的幻想，但帕姆其实要对斯普林金斯的死以及安吉拉的决裂负有责任。帕姆内疚地让安吉拉在午餐时去看望梅雷迪思，而不是照顾斯普林金斯，这就是为什么安吉拉
has to ask Dwight to do it and why Sprinkles ends up dead. Oh my gosh, ladies, I had never put that together. You are right. Pam killed Sprinkles. Well, that's going a little far. Pam killed Sprinkles. Oh my gosh, you are so mad at Pam right now. Pam is just happy. Why when Pam gets happy, does everyone turn on her? That's something I've noticed, by the way. When Pam becomes assertive, they're in particular are a bunch of men on Twitter who tweet about how they don't like Pam sassy. Nobody likes assertive Pam. Well, everyone, you're going to have to live with it. I don't give a crap about assertive Pam. It's sassy Pam guilt trip Pam. I don't give a shit Pam that I have issue with. Well, I thought you'd like that fan soap, Bob. I very much like it,
不得不让德怀特去处理，也是为什么斯普林金斯最终死掉的原因。哦，天哪，女士们，我以前从来没把这些联系在一起。你们说得对。帕姆害死了斯普林金斯。好吧，这有点过分了。帕姆害死了斯普林金斯。哦，天哪，你现在对帕姆太生气了。帕姆只是很高兴。为什么当帕姆高兴时，每个人都要针对她？顺便说一句，这是我注意到的现象。当帕姆变得自信时，推特上特别有一群男人发推文说他们不喜欢傲娇的帕姆。没人喜欢自信的帕姆。好吧，各位，你们得习惯这一点。我才不在乎什么自信的帕姆。是傲娇帕姆、内疚帕姆。我才不管那些让我在意的帕姆呢。好吧，我还以为你会喜欢那个粉丝肥皂箱环节呢。我非常喜欢它，
ladies. Thank you. I feel seen. Well, speaking of Jim and Pam, they're flirting in the break room right now. Oh, I titled this scene. Ready? What is it? Part two of our country song. Ain't no more heartbreak in the break room, baby. Oh, yes. Yes. Happy times in the break room, everyone. Happy times. Well, the camera crew breaks the fourth wall and they bring Jim and Pam into the conference room and show them footage of them kissing and driving away. This is huge. Why is the documentary crew getting involved? Remember, they left Andy floating in a lake, but they pulled Jim and Pam aside to show them this footage. They didn't say Meredith get out of the way. I don't think they saw Meredith. They were focused on Michael. I don't think the documentary
女士们。谢谢你们。我觉得自己被看见了。好了，说到吉姆和帕姆，他们现在正在休息室调情呢。哦，我给这个场景取了个名字。准备好了吗？是什么？我们乡村歌曲的第二部分。休息室里再也没有心碎了，宝贝。哦，耶。耶。休息室里的快乐时光，大家。快乐时光。然后摄像组打破了第四面墙，把吉姆和帕姆带进会议室，给他们看他们接吻并开车离开的画面。这太重大了。为什么纪录片剧组要介入？记住，他们把安迪晾在湖里，但他们把吉姆和帕姆拉到一边给他们看这段画面。他们当时可没说让梅雷迪思滚开。我觉得他们没看到梅雷迪思。他们的注意力都在迈克尔身上。我觉得纪录片
crew could have stopped that accident. I mean, there's been many times where they probably should have stepped in and they didn't. Why now? I don't know, but they get Pam to admit that she and Jim are dating. This is another Pam's ass moment where she doesn't care. She's like, you know what? We're dating. This is such a cute scene. It's so cute. It has all the feels. It's really cute and you and John are so good in it. It's a really great jam, jam moment. Well, we had a fan question from Linnea B who said, what was it like coming back from the break between season three and four to a new relationship between Jim and Pam? You guys, it was awesome. I had a great time in season four. Pam was happy. I was happy. I just spent
剧组本来也无法阻止那场事故。我的意思是，有很多次他们本该插手却没有插手。为什么偏偏是现在？我不知道，但他们让帕姆承认了她和吉姆在约会。这又是帕姆展现自信的时刻，她根本不在乎。她就像是在说，你知道吗？我们在约会。这真是个超可爱的场景。太可爱了。充满了各种情绪。真的很可爱，你和约翰在里面演得太棒了。这真的是个非常棒的“吉姆与帕姆”时刻。好吧，我们有一个来自莉娜·B的粉丝提问，她问：从第三季和第四季之间的假期回来，面对吉姆和帕姆之间的新恋情，感觉是什么样的？各位，这太棒了。我在第四季过得很开心。帕姆很开心。我也很开心。我基本上花了一整天的时间在喜剧里享受快乐，因为我不知道你怎么样，安吉拉，但我正想问你，你这一季必须经历很多情感上的动荡和哀悼，当你必须表现出嫉妒或悲伤时，这真的很伤神。这确实很伤神。嗯，确实如此。扮演悲伤很伤神。扮演生气很有趣。
all day being happy in a comedy, basically, because I don't know about you, Angela, but I was going to ask you, you have to play this season in a lot of emotional turmoil and mourning, and it takes a toll when you have to play jealousy or you have to play sad. It does take a toll. Well, it does. Playing sad takes a toll. Playing angry is fun. Yeah, I'll say that because I loved the juxtaposition from this very sweet, cute moment with Jim and Pam to me, body checking Dwight by the file cabinet. It's so great. And that whole scene that I have with Rain over by accounting where I'm backing my chair into him, we had such a great time with that. That was so much fun.
是的，我得这么说，因为我喜欢从吉姆和帕姆这个非常甜蜜、可爱的时刻，到我用身体冲撞文件柜旁的德怀特的这种强烈对比。真是太棒了。我和雷恩在会计部门旁边的整场戏，我把椅子往后撞向他，我们拍得太开心了。那真的太有趣了。
Well, that is a really good scene. Dwight seems to think you're going to feel better after you run the 5k because exercise helps with depression. And you're just like, you're not getting it. I'm not depressed. I'm pissed off. You're grieving. I'm grieving and I'm angry. Yes. So now we go into the conference room, Angela, Jim, Michael, Pam and Dwight are putting sort of the finishing touches on the fun run plans. And Michael wants a giant check. What is this thing with giant checks? He got a giant check in product recall. Yeah, I don't know. I think I swear, I think it goes back to when he was a little kid. And that owl came to his assembly in a costume with props. This is how you get people's attention, how you get them to care about things. You have big props and
好吧，那真是一场好戏。德怀特似乎觉得你跑完5公里后会感觉好点，因为运动有助于缓解抑郁。而你的反应就像是，你根本不懂。我不是抑郁。我是气炸了。你在悲伤。我在悲伤，而且我很生气。是的。所以现在我们进入会议室，安吉拉、吉姆、迈克尔、帕姆和德怀特正在为趣味跑步计划做最后的收尾工作。迈克尔想要一张巨大的支票。这巨型支票到底是怎么回事？他在产品召回那一集也拿到过一张巨型支票。是的，我不知道。我觉得，我发誓，这得追溯到他还是个小男孩的时候。那只猫头鹰穿着道具服装来到了他的学校集会上。这就是你如何吸引别人的注意力，如何让他们在乎某些事情的方式。你要有巨大的道具和
costumes and outfits. Why have we not explored Michael's feelings about carrot top? The most famous prop comic? I think he loves carrot top. And I think he loves, who's the guy that hit all the watermelons? Gallagher. Gallagher. Yeah, I think you're right. Well, here's what he wants. He wants a giant check, even though it will eat up 25% of their funds. He wants a rabies doctor to present the check. Yeah. Jim suggests maybe they hire a nurse, like by the hour, like you would for a party. Michael's like, sounds great. Dwight suggests they just donate the money to Meredith's son's college fund. Dwight is the only person making sense in this meeting. Yes, surprisingly, Dwight has the best idea. Jim and Pam are just egging
戏服和服装。为什么我们从来没有探讨过迈克尔对萝卜头（Carrot Top）的感受？那个最著名的道具喜剧演员？我想他一定很爱萝卜头。而且我觉得他很喜欢，那个用西瓜砸人的家伙是谁？加拉格尔（Gallagher）。加拉格尔。是的，我觉得你说得对。好吧，这就是他想要的。他想要一张巨型支票，尽管这会花光他们25%的资金。他想要一个狂犬病医生来颁发支票。是的。吉姆建议或许他们可以雇一个护士，按小时计费，就像办派对那样。迈克尔听了觉得：听起来不错。德怀特建议他们直接把钱捐给梅雷迪思儿子的大学基金。德怀特是这场会议里唯一一个脑子清醒的人。是的，出人意料的是，德怀特想出了最好的主意。吉姆和帕姆只是在一旁煽风点火。
Michael on. But Michael's like, have you seen that kid? He's not going to college. Exactly. Well, I think we should take a break here, Jenna. And when we come back, we might need to talk about a dangling participle. It's an accidental flashing. He did say come in. I agree. Yes. All right, we'll be back. All right, we are back and Pam's about to get the shock of her life. Jenna, how did you film this? Okay, so Pam is going into tell Michael something, right? She knocks on the door. She wants to tell him that 5K means five kilometers, not 5,000 miles. Right. Right. And he says come in and she opens the door and he's decided to change into his running outfit in his office. Yeah. And he is nude from the waist down. And Pam is shocked. Well, this was a really interesting
但迈克尔却说：你们见过那个孩子吗？他根本不会去上大学。确实如此。好吧，我觉得我们在这里应该休息一下，珍娜。等我们回来，我们可能得讨论一下悬垂分词（dangling participle）。那是一次意外的走光。他的确说过请进。我同意。好的，我们要回来了。好的，我们回来了，帕姆即将迎来她一生中最大的震惊。珍娜，你们是怎么拍这一幕的？好吧，所以帕姆走进去要告诉迈克尔一件事，对吧？她敲了门。她想告诉他5K指的是五公里，而不是五千英里。对。对。然后他说请进，她推开门，而他决定在办公室里换上他的跑步服装。对。而且他腰部以下全裸。帕姆惊呆了。好吧，这真是一个非常有趣的
scene to film. We had a fan question from Terra Nunez. When Pam walks in on Michael naked, what was Steve actually wearing? Steve was actually wearing like a flesh colored Speedo. It's still not pleasant to look at guys. Those reactions are honest. Whenever anyone has to wear a flesh covered anything, it's just off putting. Yeah, you kind of look like a like a Ken doll or a Barbie doll or something. Yeah. It's very weird. You still are seeing outlines. Right. Anyway, the thing that was difficult here when we were shooting it and we shot this several times because Pam has to get far enough into the room and open the door wide enough that the camera can see Michael because in my early takes of this, I can see him, but the camera wasn't catching it because I was reacting
拍摄场景。我们有一个来自特拉·努涅斯的粉丝提问：当帕姆撞见全裸的迈克尔时，史蒂夫实际上穿了什么？史蒂夫其实穿了一条肉色的Speedo泳裤。大家看这个还是会觉得很不舒服。那些反应都是真实的。每当任何人不得不穿任何肉色的东西时，就是会让人觉得倒胃口。对，你看起来有点像肯尼娃娃或者芭比娃娃之类的。对。这太诡异了。你还是能看到轮廓。对。不管怎样，我们在拍这场戏时困难的地方在于，我们拍了好几次，因为帕姆必须走进房间足够深，并把门开得足够大，让摄像机能看到迈克尔，因为在我早期的拍摄中，我能看到他，但摄像机没有拍到，因为我的反应
too quickly. You're pulling the door shut too fast. Yeah. Yeah. So the first thing that we did was Greg said, why don't you be looking at the paper longer and like give a look to camera as you're opening the door? Like, can you believe he thinks it's 5000 miles so that I can get the door open wider for camera to see him almost before I see him? So that's how we ended up fixing that problem. But it was very, very funny. We were laughing a lot during this scene. Lady, after this aired, a friend of mine and I were talking about this episode, and I'll never forget it because I heard a term I'd never heard before in my life. And they said, this is a thing sometimes guys will do. I don't know where they do it, but it's called shirt cocking. Oh, and it's a thing.
太快了。你把门关得太快了。对。对。所以我们做的第一件事就是格雷格说，你为什么不看文件时间长一点，然后在开门时往镜头那边看一眼？就像是，天哪，他居然觉得那是五千英里？这样我就可以把门为摄像机开得更大一些，几乎在我看到他之前摄像机就能看到他。所以我们最终就是这样解决那个问题的。但这个过程真的非常非常搞笑。我们在拍这场戏时笑了很多次。天哪，在这集播出后，我和一个朋友在聊这一集，我永远不会忘记，因为我听到一个我这辈子从未听过的词。他们说，这是有时男人会做的一件事。我不知道他们在哪里做，但这叫“露半截”（shirt cocking）。哦，这真的是个现象。
Okay. And if you look it up, it says it's a shirt cocking is a verb and it's when a man wears a t-shirt but goes naked from the waist down. Oh, oh, listen to this. This practice is a natural outgrowth of Burning Man events, which value radical self expression, but are held in clothing optional environments. Oh, I've never been to Burning Man. Well, neither have I, but apparently this happens there guys. Well, I've never been shirt cocked either. I've never, I've never been shirt cocked, but beware it happens. It's a thing. I guess it's a thing in the desert guys where people get together to have radical experiences. Well, Michael shirt cocks Pam and Pam tells Jim that the incident is now burned into her brain. Back in
好的。如果你去查一下，它说“shirt cocking”是一个动词，指的是一个男人只穿一件T恤，但腰部以下全裸。哦，哦，听这个：这种做法是火人节活动的自然延伸，该活动崇尚激进的自我表达，但却是在服装可选的环境下举办的。哦，我从来没去过火人节。好吧，我也没有，但显然这群人在那里会发生这种事。好吧，我也从来没“露半截”过。我从来没有，我从来没有“露半截”，但小心这真的会发生。这是个真事。我想这是沙漠里的一群人聚在一起体验极端的活动时会做的事吧。好吧，迈克尔对帕姆“露半截”，帕姆告诉吉姆这个事件现在已经深深烙印在她的脑海里了。回到
the break room. Jim and Pam don't hang out at front reception anymore. They just go to the break room to hang out and have their little conversations. Yeah, happiness in the break room. The break room is a great place now. Well, Michael knocks on the break room door and enters. He's trying to teach Pam how to properly enter a room. Oh, can I come in? Yeah. Yeah. And Pam is like, you said, come in. You said, come in. Well, Pam has a major Pam sass moment. She says, I didn't see where it started, but I saw where it ended. Wow. I couldn't believe that line. Wow. Pam is really just saying anything on her mind now. You're really, I see. You're right. Yeah. She's looking up celebrity porn on the computer.
休息室。吉姆和帕姆不再在前台闲逛了。他们只是去休息室闲逛并进行他们的小对话。哦，休息室里的幸福。休息室现在是个好地方了。好吧，迈克尔敲了敲休息室的门并走了进来。他正试图教帕姆如何正确地进入一个房间。哦，我可以进来吗？对。对。然后帕姆说：你说了请进。你说了请进。好吧，帕姆迎来了她标志性的“傲娇帕姆”时刻。她说：我没看见它是怎么开始的，但我看见它是怎么结束的。哇。我真不敢相信这句台词。哇。帕姆现在真的是心里想什么就说什么了。你真的，我懂了。你说得对。对。她正在电脑上查名人色情片。
She's sassing Angela. She's sassing Michael. She's not going to run in your stupid fun run. It's true. Let's get to the fun run, lady. Let's do it. We're in the parking lot. Jan is checking people in. Creed registers. He's very disappointed. There's no prize money. We find out, by the way, that Creed's birthday is November 1st, and he's going to be 82. I know. I'm so ridiculous. That was so ridiculous. Jan tells Pam to stay away from her man, heard she was peeping in on him. I know. Oh, that was so fun to do. I love doing that scene with Molaura, where she's just putting Pam in her place, and Pam is like, I, but you know, guys, Jan is no longer our boss. Yeah. She holds no authority over us. She is just there as Michael's
她对安吉拉大放厥词。她对迈克尔大放厥词。她才不会去跑你们那该死的趣味跑步呢。确实如此。我们进入趣味跑步环节吧，各位。开始吧。我们在停车场。简正在给人们登记。克里德登记了。他非常失望。没有奖金。顺便我们发现，克里德的生日是11月1日，他就要82岁了。我知道。太荒谬了。真是太荒谬了。简告诉帕姆离她的男人远点，听说她在偷窥他。我知道。哦，拍那段太好玩了。我喜欢和莫劳拉一起拍那场戏，她把帕姆压制得死死的，而帕姆就像是，我，但是你知道吗，各位，简已经不是我们的老板了。对。她对我们没有任何权力了。她现在只是作为迈克尔的
girlfriend. Well, I have to tell you something. So all of this is happening while you have this scene between Pam and Jan going on. There is a scene between Bob, Vance, Phyllis, and Angela. So in the background where Toby is stretching, Angela is standing there, and Phyllis and Bob walk up, and Bob points to her shirt and says, oh, oh, is that, is that the cat? And, and he turns to Phyllis and says, is that the one that Meredith and Phyllis quickly cuts him off and goes, no, no, no. And then Angela spits on Bob. What? And storms off. What is happening in that scene? Did Meredith do something to one of your other cats? I have so many questions. What has Meredith done to one of her cats? It certainly might explain why Angela really does not like Meredith. But man,
女朋友呆在那里。好吧，我得告诉你一件事。所有这些事情发生的同时，帕姆和简正在演那场戏。托比在拉伸的时候，背景里发生了另一场戏，是关于鲍勃·万斯、菲莉丝和安吉拉的。安吉拉站在那里，菲莉丝和鲍勃走了过来，鲍勃指着她的衣服说，哦，哦，那是，那是那只猫吗？然后，他转过身对菲莉丝说，那是梅雷迪思和菲莉丝迅速打断他说，不，不，不。然后安吉拉向鲍勃吐了口水。什么？然后气冲冲地走了。那场戏里到底发生了什么？梅雷迪思对你的其他猫做什么了吗？我有太多问题了。梅雷迪思对她的其中一只猫做什么了？这当然可以解释为什么安吉拉真的很不喜欢梅雷迪思。但是天哪，
Angela is talking about angry. She spits at Bob. Wow. Yeah. Well, now Michael welcomes everyone, and he gives a speech where he sort of warns everybody of the dangers of rabies. In the background, then Daryl is feeding a peanut to a squirrel. It was such that is such a random funny joke. That's a very Simpsons-esque joke, if you ask me. I loved it. And I love when Michael was like, stop and he's like, but he's so happy. Well, then we have Elizabeth, the stripper, is back, Jackie DeBotton, she walks in and this little nurse's outfit to present Michael with the giant check made out to science. Just science. Yeah. $340 to science. Just a piece of cardboard that costs $200 for nothing. And when Michael sees Elizabeth in her outfit, he's like, oh my
安吉拉居然说生气就生气。她向鲍勃吐口水。哇。好吧，现在迈克尔欢迎大家，并发表了一场演讲，他在演讲中向大家警告了狂犬病的危险。而在背景里，达里尔正在给一只松鼠喂花生。这真是一个极其随意的搞笑笑话。如果你问我的话，这非常具有辛普森一家的风格。我太喜欢了。我喜欢迈克尔说“停下”，而他却说“可是它那么开心”。好吧，接着伊丽莎白，那个脱衣舞娘回来了，杰基·德博顿，她穿着这套可爱的护士服走进来，给迈克尔送上一张开给“科学”的巨型支票。仅仅是科学。对。340美元给科学。只是一张花了两百块钱却毫无用处的纸板。当迈克尔看到伊丽莎白穿着这身衣服时，他就像是：哦，天哪，你回去拿学位了。对。太惊人了。好吧，我有一个关于戏服的小花絮。我想我知道你的花絮是什么。哦，真的吗？说吧。好吧。
gosh, you went back for your degree. Yeah. Amazing. Well, I have a little wardrobe tidbit. I think I know your tidbit. Oh, really? Go. All right. Carrie told me that this nurse's outfit was custom made. And if you notice, she had to make it a red circle with a white cross in the middle. And this is because the red cross does not like their symbol to be used for fictional content. So she could not have a red cross in a white circle. She had to invert it. Yes, lady. Well, do you know that that is the same costume that Angela Martin wore in season seven? They saved that costume. Season seven, the Halloween episode where we have a costume contest. I wore that outfit. What? Yep. I wore that outfit. The exact same one. And it was a little too big
凯瑞告诉我这套护士服是定制的。如果你注意到的话，她必须把它做成中间带有白十字的红圈。这是因为红十字会不喜欢他们的标志被用于虚构内容。所以她不能在白圈里放红十字。她必须把它反过来。是的，各位。你知道吗，那是安吉拉·马丁在第七季穿过的同一套服装。他们把那套衣服保存下来了。第七季，我们举办服装大赛的那集万圣节。我穿过那套衣服。什么？是的。我穿了一套衣服。一模一样的。而且它对我来说有点太大。所以我不得不在里面穿一件小蕾丝吊带背心。而且，你知道的，我们以后会聊到第七季，但他们给了我鸡胸肉垫（假胸垫）来把整套衣服撑大一点。是的。同一套衣服。哇。我猜在我们的办公室世界里，这就像是一套你可以买得到的小服装，我猜。但凯瑞·贝内特告诉我那是她亲手做的。就是那个。你穿着它。你可以看到它有同样的白十字，同样的帽子。我只是穿了一件背心，因为衣服稍微有点大。这太疯狂了。我知道。我可以说。
for me. So I had to wear a little lace tank top underneath it. And, you know, we'll get to season seven, but they gave me the chicken cutlets to make everything a little bigger. Yep. Same costume. Wow. I guess in our Dunder Mifflin world, this is like a little costume that you could buy, I guess. But Carrie Bennett told me that she made it. There it is. You're wearing it. And you can see it's this same white cross, the same hat. I just have a tank top because it's a little big. That is crazy. I know. I could say. Well, speaking of crazy, Michael is now downing some fettuccine Alfredo. Just downing it. He's carboloading before the run. Is that a thing? Do people carboload? They do, but like not moments before they run, right? I looked it up.
好吧，说到疯狂，迈克尔现在正在大口大口地吃着 fettuccine Alfredo（奶油宽面）。直接狂吞。他在跑步前补充碳水化合物。这是真事吗？人们真的会在跑步前补充碳水化合物吗？会的，但不是在跑步前几分钟，对吧？我查过了。在这个时刻发生了两件事。首先，我们有一个假装拿袋子的道具，假袋子，假道具袋。德怀特拿着的那个袋子不是一个真正的袋子。那是那种不会发出噪音的袋子之一。关于碳水化合物补充，情况是这样的。各位，这是人们会做的一件事，但建议你在一项高强度运动的前一周进行。前一周。是的。高强度活动前一周。是的。你之所以要在前一周进行碳水化合物补充，是为了增加储存在你肌肉中的糖原，对吧？这样你就可以在进行高强度活动时消耗这些糖原。你不能在几分钟前才这么做。太恶心了。太恶心了。太恶心了。很多人写信问史蒂夫
There's two things happening in this moment. First of all, we have a fakey bag catch, fakey bag, fakey prop bag. That bag that Dwight is holding is not a real bag. It's one of the ones that doesn't make noise. And here's the thing about carboloading. So guys, this is something that people will do, but it's recommended that you do it the week before a high. A week before. Yeah. A week before a high endurance activity. Yeah. The reason why you do this carboload the week before is to boost the glycogen that's stored in your muscles, right? So you can sort of burn on that while you're doing your high endurance activity. You don't do it minutes before. It's so gross. So gross. It's so gross. A lot of people wrote in asking how much fettuccine
不得不吃多少宽面。几乎没有。不知道你们有没有注意到，在史蒂夫真正把宽面吞下去之前，我们把镜头切走了。他们现场准备了一个桶。所以他会把一大堆面塞进嘴里，然后吐出来。谢天谢地。因为那一周每天的气温都快接近100华氏度（约38摄氏度）了。是的。我们在外面，外面很热，还在吃宽面。我们能聊聊德怀特为了开始比赛而鸣枪的那把巨大无比的枪吗？那可不是发令枪，是一把带有真子弹的真正的枪。很显然，我们发射的是空包弹，但搞什么鬼？我知道。根据“办公室百科”（Dunderpedia），德怀特使用的是一把6英寸的柯尔特蟒蛇左轮手枪（Colt Anaconda），这和《肮脏的哈里》里用的是同一种口径的枪。好吧，这太荒谬了。不过我相信他的确会有一把克林特·伊斯特伍德开过的枪，
Steve had to eat. Pretty much none. I don't know if you noticed, but we cut away before he has to really swallow the fettuccine. They had a bucket there. So he would shove a bunch in his mouth and he would spit it out. Thank God. Because it was almost 100 degrees that week every day. Yeah. And we were outside hot outside eating fettuccine. Can we talk about the ginormous gun that Dwight shoots off to start the race? Not a starter's pistol, an actual gun with actual bullets in it. Obviously, we shot off blanks, but what the heck? I know. So according to Dunderpedia, Dwight uses a six inch Colt Anaconda and it's the same caliber gun used by Dirty Harry. Well, it's ridiculous. I believe though that he would have some gun that Clint Eastwood fired,
就像肮脏哈里的枪一样。这很符合他的作风。这非常适合他的角色。好吧，比赛正在进行。我们鸣枪了。克里德、斯坦利和奥斯卡立刻上了一辆出租车。是的。这太棒了。斯坦利说他今天要锻炼。他会想出一个办法来避免为一个愚蠢的理由跑步。是的。他们三个人都有访谈镜头和被删减的片段，讲述他们为什么不跑。斯坦利有一个被删减的备选台词，说当他跑步时，他的脚会肿得像烤肉一样大，而你绝对不想看到那一幕。哦，好吧，安吉拉·马丁肯定不想。她不喜欢恶心的脚。不。好吧，我们算是看到了每个人的态度，对吧？比如安迪要跑，迈克尔跑得飞快。而正是在这个时候，我们发现帕姆和吉姆
like a Dirty Harry gun. That tracks. It's perfect for his character. Well, the race is underway. We fired this gun. Creed, Stanley and Oscar immediately get into a cab. Yeah. Which is amazing. Stanley says he will work out today. He will work out a way to avoid running for a stupid cause. Yeah. They all three have talking heads and deleted scenes that talk about why they're not doing it. Stanley had an alt that said when he runs his feet swell up to the size of a pot roast and you don't want to see that. Oh, well, Angela Martin certainly would not. She does not like gross feet. No. Well, we sort of see everybody's approach, right? Like Andy's going to run, Michael's going really fast. And this is when we find out that Pam and Jim are
正开开心心地手挽着手，在最后一名慢慢散步。安迪打算跟在凯文后面吃尾流。好吧，现在我们迎来了一个我非常喜欢的场景，简正在给跑步者分发不知怎么从她负责登记的起跑线移到一个新桌子上的水，而人们甚至还没跑到她那里。我觉得这很有意思。是的。我猜她显然是开车过去的。她飞快地开车过去的。好吧，迈克尔拒绝喝水。他解释说狂犬病患者对水有一种理性的痛恨，所以拒绝喝水真的是他能做的最起码的事情了。好吧，我查过了。安吉拉，你知道的，上周我跟你聊了很多关于狂犬病的事情，以及如果你被动物咬伤注射疫苗的重要性。
happily in last place together just strolling. Andy's going to draft behind Kevin. Well, now we have a scene that I love so much where Jan is handing out water to the runners. She's somehow moved from the starting line where she was checking people in to a new table where she's handing out waters and people haven't even gotten to her yet. I found that interesting. Yeah. She obviously drove, I guess. She quickly drove. Well, Michael refuses to take the water. He explains that rabies victims have to live within a rational hatred of water so it's really the least he can do to refuse the water. Well, I looked it up. Angela, you know, last week I told you a lot about rabies and the importance of getting a shot if you're ever bitten by an animal.
嘿，我可没查过。事实上，我给自己记了个便签，问珍娜，这个狂犬病专家，这是真的吗？不，你才没有。我必须承认，多亏了这个播客，我对狂犬病的了解比我以前想象的要多得多。但这种病症被称为恐水症，是对水的一种非理性的恐惧，它确实会出现在狂犬病晚期的症状中。但原因如下。基本上，患者开始害怕液体是因为吞咽实在是太痛苦了。就像他们不想喝水或吃任何东西一样。所以并不是水碰触到他们会让他们烦恼，而是摄入任何东西都变得极其痛苦，这才是原因。这太可怕了。这太可怕了。狂犬病是一种可怕的疾病。我怎么强调都不为过，如果你被动物咬了，去打那一针是多么重要。
Hey, I did not look it up. In fact, I wrote myself a note, asked Jenna, rabies expert, is this true? No, you did not. I have to say I do know a lot more about rabies than I ever thought I would thanks to this podcast. But this condition is called hydrophobia and it is an irrational fear of water and it does present itself in the advanced stages of the disease of rabies. But here's why. Basically, patients start to fear liquids because it is so painful to swallow. Like they don't want to drink or eat anything. So it's not like having water touch them would bother them, but ingesting anything becomes so painful that that's why. This is horrible. This is horrible. Rabies is a horrible disease. I cannot stress enough how important it is to get
好吧，我们还没提到托比跑步路过时喝了一大口水，但把大部分都泼到了简身上。是的，这是真的。好吧，托比表现得棒极了，我们马上就会知道原因。迈克尔因为那些宽面条而状态不佳。是的。但德怀特告诉他他会没事的。你可能还是会赢，因为他在托比的咖啡里放了易蒙停（Imodium）。迈克尔兴奋极了。他就像是：太棒了。然后说：等等，你不是指“X-Lax”（泻药）吧？是的。德怀特帮了托比。是的。我想指出关于这个场景的一点。在这场戏中，我发誓迈克尔和德怀特跑过了奥斯卡的家，或者至少是我们用作奥斯卡家的那个拍摄地点。所以，我查了一下，是的，我们确实是在谢尔曼奥克斯（Sherman Oaks）的那条街上拍摄的，那里有奥斯卡的家。我们在那里拍了很多次。离我们的片场非常近，而且，是的，我觉得我们跑过了奥斯卡家的所在地。我们因为种种原因在那里拍了很多次，而且谢尔曼奥克斯的这个特定街区有着非常棒的、古老的、巨大的树木，比起洛杉矶通常的面貌，它可能更像东海岸。
that shot if you are bitten by an animal. Well, we also didn't mention that Toby ran by and took a swig of water, but threw most of it on Jan. Yes, this is true. Well, Toby's doing great and we're about to find out why. Michael is not doing well because of the fettuccine. Yeah. But Dwight tells him he's going to be fine. You'll probably still win because he put a modium in Toby's coffee. Michael's so excited. He's like, excellent. And then goes, wait, don't you mean X-Lux? Yes. Dwight has helped Toby. Yeah. I want to point something out about this scene. During this scene, I swear Michael and Dwight run past Oscar's house or at least the location that we used for Oscar's house. So, I looked it up and, yes, we are filming on the same street in Sherman Oaks that has Oscar's
与此同时，安迪的乳头开始被磨破了，而克里德、斯坦利和奥斯卡则在一个露天咖啡馆里。他们又点了一轮饮料。我喜欢他们的风格。是的。而帕姆和吉姆现在要在一家房产清算拍卖会（estate sale）停下来。我太喜欢房产清算拍卖会了。我妈妈，这让我想起了我妈妈。无论我们去哪里，只要进行任何形式的公路旅行，如果我们看到写着“庭院拍卖”、“车库拍卖”、“房产清算拍卖”的牌子，我妈妈真的会把车开到路边停下。
house. We filmed there a lot. It was really close to our set and, yeah, I think we run past the location of Oscar's house. We filmed there a lot for all those reasons and also this particular neighborhood in Sherman Oaks has really great old, old, huge trees that might resemble the east coast more than normally what LA would look like. Yeah. Meanwhile, Andy's nipples are starting to chafe and Creed, Stanley, and Oscar are at like an outside cafe. They've ordered another round of drinks. I like their style. Yes. And Pam and Jim are now going to stop at an estate sale. I love estate sales. My mom, this makes me think of my mom. Whenever we went anywhere, any kind of road trip, if we saw a sign that said yard sale, garage sale, estate sale,
好吧，在我上大学二年级时，我有了自己的公寓，在我回学校前的那个夏天，我妈妈带我去了各种房产清算拍卖会和车库拍卖会，那正是我买下所有的盘子、锅碗瓢盆以及我厨房需要的所有东西的地方，我到现在还保留着其中一些东西。我至今还留着一个从我们为了买齐上大学的东西而去的车库拍卖会上买回来的烘焙烤盘。我还留着一块很小的厨房装饰艺术品。上面画着一个梨和几串葡萄，就像是某个人制作了这个图案，然后找了一块木头，在上面刷了亮漆。你知道我的意思吗？是的。这就是那种带着俗气美感的厨房小艺术品，我是从一个车库拍卖会上买来的。我太喜欢了。我当时也这么做。我太喜欢房产清算拍卖会和车库拍卖会了，因为我觉得这是一种非常棒的循环利用方式。你知道的，你不需要买所有崭新的东西。当别人用完了，你就接着用。我太喜欢了。我也非常喜欢。我总是很喜欢去想背后的故事是什么。比如，那个带有一个小缺口的绿色碗背后有着什么样的故事？现在它归我了。是的，我同意。好吧，现在我喜欢瑞安和花哨的公司总部打电话给分公司，但没有人接听，他听到了一条留言，上面说：你已接通邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司的办公室。目前，全体员工都在外面参加迈克尔·斯科特·邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司狂犬病意识业余职业者趣味跑步比赛。然后迈克尔插话道：
my mom would literally pull off the road. Well, in my sophomore year of college, I got my own apartment and the summer before I went back to school, my mom took me around to estate sales and garage sales and that's where I bought all of my dishes and my pots and pans and all the stuff I was going to need for my kitchen and I still have some of that stuff. I still have a baking dish from one of the garage sales that we went to in order to get all my stuff for college. I still have a little piece of like kitchen art. It's like a pear and some grapes and it's like someone made this, someone made the image and then got a piece of wood and then shellacked over it. Do you know what I mean? Yes. And it's this sort of kitschy little piece of kitchen art
那是你的声音。然后迈克尔插话说道：为了治愈。然后帕姆说：请留言。我觉得这太搞笑了。我觉得太好笑了。瑞安就像是，好吧，你知道的，迈克尔当时就盘旋在帕姆的肩膀上方，看着她录制了那条外发留言。哦，天哪。我很想看看他让她重录了多少遍，直到他们把这条留言录对。好吧，现在，德怀特正试图对安吉拉甜言蜜语。确实如此，他跑在她身旁，告诉她她看起来像一颗纽扣一样可爱。她可不吃这一套。她根本不想听。而且有很多事情让这场戏比看起来要棘手得多。我们必须一边跑步一边说所有的台词。但我们又不能跑得太快，以至于
and I got it at a garage sale. I love that. I did that too. I love estate sales and garage sales because I think there's such a great way to recycle and reuse. You know, you don't have to buy everything new. When someone's done with it, use it. I love that. I love that too. I always love the idea of what that story was. Like what, what did that green bowl with that one little chip? What was that about? Now I'm going to have it. Yes, I agree. Well, now I love that Ryan and Fancy Corporate calls Dunder Mifflin and no one is answering and he gets this message that says, you've reached the offices of Dunder Mifflin Scranton. Currently, the entire staff is out doing the Michael Scott DMSMPMC Rabies Awareness Pro Am Fun Run Race. And then Michael chimes in.
摄像机拍不到史蒂夫，他当时就定位在我们身后、我们俩之间。我们不能跑得离彼此太近。而且我们必须掌握好节奏，因为摄像机在捕捉我们作为前景画面，而迈克尔在背景里。我能想象这有多难。而且我们能用的人行道只有那么长。好吧，我们在人行道上有一个必须停下来的特定地点。而且我们必须努力每次都准确踩到那个位置，因为随后我们会遇到邻居，然后我们有一段我非常喜欢的精彩互动，我们说：没什么。德怀特说：我在抢劫她。我说：没事。然后同时，我们说：没什么。接着我们又立刻回到了刚才的谈话中。好吧，我们有一个来自斯蒂芬妮·贝利和黛比·凯的粉丝提问。更像是一个陈述。
That's all your voice. And Michael chimes in and goes for the cure. And then Pam says, leave a message. I thought it was hilarious. I thought it was so funny. And Ryan is like, well, you know, Michael is just hovering over Pam's shoulder as she created that outgoing message. Oh my goodness. I would love to have seen how many like ways that he made her say it until they got it right. Well, now Lady Dwight is going to try to sweet talk Angela. He is, he runs up next to her, tells her she looks cute as a button. She's not, she's not into it. She doesn't want to hear it. And there were a lot of things that made this scene a little trickier than it looks. We had to deliver all of our dialogue while running. But we couldn't run so fast that
安吉拉，作为一个不常跑步的人，你的姿势真的很棒。是吗？我也这么觉得。我觉得你跑步的姿势非常可爱。好吧，谢谢。我的意思是，我高中时可是跑过越野赛的，各位。也许在我大脑的某个角落，记忆还在吧。好吧，原来如此。你是什么时候一边跑越野，一边打篮球还吹长号的？我简直无法理解。还有网球。我还是个拉拉队员。我在高中的时候可是个大忙人，珍娜。我妈妈的态度就是，如果你很忙，你就没有时间惹麻烦。好吧，你的确很忙。我非常忙。我还想给你读一读帕特里克·赖特的这封信。好的。因为我和帕特里克英雄所见略同。帕特里克是这么说的：我真的很想表达我对安吉拉作为一名演员的敬意，
you would never see Steve, who was positioned just behind us in between us. We couldn't run too close to one another. And we had to paste this out because the camera was getting us in the foreground and Michael in the background. I imagine it was difficult. Also, we only had so much sidewalk. Well, we had a specific place we had to stop to on the sidewalk. And we had to try to hit that same mark every time because then we see the neighbor and we have this great moment that I love where, where we're like, it's nothing. And Dwight's like, I'm robbing her. And I'm like, it's fine. And then at the same time, we're like, it's nothing. And then we go right back to our conversation we were having. Well, we had a fan question from Steph Bailey and Debbie Kaye. Kind of more of a statement.
尤其是在这一集中。她完美融合了悲剧色彩的搞笑以及令人心碎的特质。她在整集里奉献了如此精湛细腻的表演。作为观众，我们真的为她在这段故事中遭受的伤害和愤怒感同身受。当我看到她逃离德怀特时，我的心都碎了，她对所爱之人的爱慕，但与此同时又支离破碎。演员阵容中每个人的表演都一如既往地极其精彩。但我忍不住要特别挑出安吉拉，称赞她精湛的演技。哦，这太暖心了。谢谢。我真的非常感激。我们真的能感受到安吉拉在这里面临的内心挣扎，因为德怀特承认他杀了斯普林金斯。他是出于仁慈安乐死了斯普林金斯。而且，你知道的，德怀特试图用最仁慈的方式去做这件事，而且在他脑海里这也是出于所有正确的理由，对吧？
Angela, for not being a runner, you have really great form. Do I? I thought so too. I thought you were a very cute runner. Well, thank you. I mean, I ran cross country in high school, you guys. Maybe somewhere in the back of my brain, it was still there. Well, there you go. When were you running cross country while also playing basketball and trombone? I don't understand. And tennis. And I was a cheerleader. I was busy in high school, Jenna. This was my mom's attitude, was if you're busy, you don't have time for trouble. Well, you were busy. I was very busy. I also want to read you this letter from Patrick Wright. Okay. Because I agree with Patrick. Here's what Patrick had to say. I really wanted to express my respect for Angela as an actress,
是的。从他的角度来看，他给她喂了抗组胺药直到她睡着。而安吉拉却说：但后来她把药吐出来了，她还试图拼命抓挠着逃出来。她就像是在说：你为什么不先跟我商量一下？这怎么能不算是一场对话呢？如果这是你认为需要采取的解决方案，为什么不先跟我谈谈？这场戏里有很悲伤的时刻。而且有些时刻很明显写了笑话，但我必须非常真诚地把它说出来，比如“猫的天堂是一个美丽的地方，但如果你是被安乐死送去的，你是去不了那里的，你知道吗？”是的。而且，格雷格给我的其中一个笔记是，当你跑开时，你知道的，德怀特伸手去抓你，我说：你不懂。
especially in this episode. She is a mixture of tragically funny and also just heartbreaking. She gives such a fabulous nuance performance throughout this entire episode. We as an audience truly feel for her hurt and anger throughout the story. And my heart broke as she runs away from Dwight with her adoration of the man she loves, but at the same time, shattered. The performances from everyone in the cast was brilliant as always. But I felt compelled to single out Angela for her marvelous acting. Oh, that is so nice. Thank you. I so appreciate that. We really feel Angela being torn here because Dwight admits he killed sprinkles. He mercy killed sprinkles. And, you know, Dwight tried to do it in the kindest way and for all the right reasons in his mind, right?
然后我一边跑开一边开始哭。他说，你知道的，德怀特不明白的是，对你来说这是不可原谅的。是的。而你深爱这个男人，但他却彻底斩断了这份羁绊。你觉得你再也无法和他在一起了，但德怀特现在还不知道这一点，只有你自己心里清楚。好吧，我在现实中的恋爱关系中也经历过这种事，当你正在恋爱，爱得深沉，这段感情充满了许诺和乐观。然后发生了一些事，对方的反应或行为方式让你意识到你们之间存在着价值观上的根本差异。是的。而她心里清楚，她知道自己无法再用同样的眼光看待他了。正如我们所知，要让她原谅他，将会需要非常、非常、非常长的时间。是的。好吧，你猜怎么着？吉姆和帕姆买
Yeah. In his perspective and gave her antihistamines until she fell asleep. And then Angela's like, but then she threw them up and she tried to claw her way out. And she's like, why didn't you talk to me about this first? Like, how is this not a conversation? If this was the solution you thought needed to happen, why not talk to me about this? And there are sad moments to the scene. And there's these moments where obviously there's a joke written, but I have to say it really earnestly, like the cat heaven is a beautiful place, but you don't get there if you're euthanized, you know? Yeah. And, but one of the notes Greg gave me was as you run away, you know, Dwight's like reaching out for you and I say, you don't understand.
了一个台灯。仅仅是一个台灯底座。是的，只要八美元，现在轮到吉姆拿着它了。这是一个奇怪的选择，这个绿色的台灯。它看起来像两根章鱼触手在手拉手什么的。我不知道这东西到底是怎么回事。如果这就是帕姆想买的台灯，那吉姆会对帕姆的品味作何感想？他会不会担心有一天同居，甚至一起共用一个家？这台灯确实不怎么样，而且迈克尔也快撑不下去了。菲莉丝和鲍勃超越了他。我的意思是，他正躺在地上。他的嘴唇全白了。他看起来状况很糟。他看起来不像是能撑到终点的人。与此同时，托比赢得了比赛。是的。而且我觉得凯利在终点线拿着手机的那个样子简直太绝了。
And I kind of start to cry as I run away. And he's, he said, you know, what Dwight isn't getting is that this is unforgivable for you. Yeah. And you love this man, but he has severed this bond. You don't think you can be with him anymore, but Dwight doesn't know that yet, but you know it. Well, I've had this happen in relationships where you're dating and you're so in love, and the relationship is just all promise and optimism. And then something happens and the person reacts or acts in such a way that you realize there is a fundamental difference of values. Yeah. And, and she knows it and she knows she can't see him the same way. And it will take a very, very, very long time as we know for her to forgive him. Yeah. Well, guess what? Jim and Pam bought
是的。他问：我们在哪儿？她回答：我们离办公室大约五公里。托比说：迈克尔为什么不把它设计成一个圆圈呢？不，他不可能把它搞得简单。弄成了一条直线。好吧，这很有趣。他们所在的那个地方实际上就正好在我们真正的办公室外面。那是我们拍摄时所在的萨塔科伊街（Satakoy Street）。所以我们其实离得很近。就像我们，我们在结束时直接走回片场就行了。是的。所以我们最终结束的地方确实离我们的办公室非常近。你知道的，这挺有意思的，因为帕姆，我觉得她本来想给迈克尔打气，但她却说：不，你撑不住了。这更像是“帕姆式的犀利吐槽”，意思是“有其他人更擅长鼓励别人，你为什么不干脆放弃算了”。
a lamp. Just the base of a lamp. Yeah, it was eight dollars and now Jim gets to carry it. It's an odd choice, this green lamp. It looks like two octopus tentacles are holding hands or something. I don't know what's happening with it. How does Jim feel about Pam's taste if this is the lamp she wanted to buy? Is he concerned about moving in together one day, maybe sharing a house? The lamp is not great, but also Michael is really struggling. Phyllis and Bob pass him up. I mean, he's laying on the ground. His lips are all white. He doesn't look good. He doesn't look like he's going to make it. In the meantime, Toby wins the race. Yeah. And I thought it was so perfect that Kelly is at the finish line like on her phone.
然后迈克尔说：你不了解我。你只见过我的阴茎。不知怎的，帕姆没有为他加油打气，反而激起了他为自己加油的斗志。他有一个访谈镜头，里面说道：跑完那个5公里是我这辈子做过最艰难的事。我吃下的 fettuccine Alfredo 比我这辈子任何时候都多，喝的水却比任何时候都少。我觉得这太搞笑了。他慢慢地、慢慢地挪过了终点线。我看到了一棵棕榈树。是的。你看到了吗？是的，我看到了。是的。39分46秒，棕榈树警报。我们没有。我猜我们当时没把它P掉。是的。我敢肯定沿途还有其他的，因为，你知道的，我们在室外拍了那么多。但他终于跨过了终点线。吉姆把那个台灯当成
Yes. And he's like, where are we? And she's like, we're about five kilometers from the office. And Toby's like, why didn't Michael make it a circle? No, I couldn't have made it easy. Made it a straight line. Well, it's interesting. So that spot where they are is pretty much right outside of our real office, actually. That was on Satakoy Street where we shot. So we actually were very, very close. Like we, we just walked back to set at the end. Yeah. So we actually did end very close to our office. You know, I guess it's interesting because Pam, like I think she's going to give Michael a pep talk, but she's like, no, you don't got this. It's more like Pamsas of like, there's other people that are better at helping people. Why don't you just let this one go?
奖杯交给了他。然后他吐了。是的。大概是什么蘑菇汤吧。哦，看起来，看起来真恶心。看起来太恶心了。太恶心了。看起来太恶心了。而且他还让呕吐物顺着下巴往下流。我就像是：快把脸擦干净。太恶心了。好吧，这一集的结尾是迈克尔在医院里。梅雷迪思坐着轮椅进了他的病房探望他。是的。有一个被删减的片段，讲的是迈克尔是因为脱水而自己办理入院的。而且他要求他童年时的儿科医生来探望他。他的儿科医生是一个非常老的老头。他说，你知道的，迈克尔其实不需要住院。他只是有点轻微脱水。说实话，这一切本来只需要一瓶水就能解决。但是，然后正当他说话时，迈克尔
And then Michael's like, you don't know me. You've just seen my penis. And somehow Pam, not cheering him on, makes him cheer himself on. And he has this talking head where he's like finishing that 5k was the hardest thing I've ever had to do. I ate more fettuccine Alfredo and drank less water than he ever has in his entire life. This was so funny to me. He slowly slowly makes his way across the finish line. And I caught a palm tree. Yeah. Did you see it? Yes, I did. Yeah. 39 minutes, 46 seconds, palm tree alert. We did not. I guess we didn't paint that one out. Yeah. I'm sure there are others along the way because, you know, we're filming outside so much. But he finally makes it across the finish line. And Jim gives him the lamp as a
说：我的棒棒糖呢？哦，天哪。这就是为什么他在和梅雷迪思在一起的这场戏里手里拿着一根棒棒糖吗？是的。因为他的儿科医生顺道来看望了他，检查了他的情况，并给了他一根棒棒糖。好吧，这根棒棒糖把我们引入了一个让人极度尴尬的收尾时刻。是的，那就是迈克尔正在吮吸那根棒棒糖。他建议他们分享它。于是他把它递给了梅雷迪思，梅雷迪思随后把它放进了自己嘴里。接着她又把它递回给迈克尔，而迈克尔却说：不，不用了，我挺好的。好吧。好吧。好吧，我们收到了来自伊莉莎泽·贾维斯和娜塔莉·贝纳里的邮件。请告诉我，迈克尔和梅雷迪思分享的那根棒棒糖在他们分享之前是换过的。他们真的分享了同一个吗？各位，我也有同感。当我看到这一幕时，根本没有剪辑。这是一个一镜到底的镜头。
trophy. And he pukes. Yeah. Probably some kind of mushroom soup. Oh, it looked, it looked gross. It looked so gross. It was so gross. It looks so gross. And he let it just dribble down his chin. I'm like, wipe that off your face. So gross. Well, this episode ends with Michael in the hospital. And Meredith has wheeled herself in to his room to visit him. Yes. There is a deleted scene that Michael checked himself into the hospital for dehydration. And he requested his childhood pediatrician come visit him. And his pediatrician is a very elderly man. And he's saying, you know, Michael doesn't really need to be in the hospital. He got a little dehydrated. Really, this all could have been solved with a bottle of water. But, and then as he's talking, Michael's
奖杯。然后他吐了。对。大概是某种蘑菇汤。哦，看起来，看起来真恶心。看起来太恶心了。太恶心了。看起来真恶心。他还让它顺着下巴往下流。我就想，把它擦干净。太恶心了。好吧，这一集的结尾是迈克尔进了医院。梅雷迪思自己坐着轮椅去他的病房看望他。是的。有一个被删掉的场景，说是迈克尔因为脱水住进了医院。他还要求他的儿时儿科医生来看望他。他的儿科医生是一个非常年迈的老人。他说，你知道，迈克尔其实没必要住院。他有点脱水。其实，这一切只要一瓶水就能解决。但是，接着在他说话的时候，迈克尔
like, where's my lollipop? Oh my gosh. Is that why he has a lollipop in this scene with Meredith? Yes. Because his pediatrician stopped by and checked in on him and gave him a lollipop. Well, the lollipop leads us to a very cringy final moment. Yes. Which is that Michael is sucking on the lollipop. And he suggests that they share it. So he hands it to Meredith, who then sort of puts it in her mouth. And then she offers it back to Michael and he says, nah, no, I'm good. Good. Good. Well, we had some mail from Eliza Jarvis and Natalie Benari. Please tell me the lollipop Michael shares with Meredith is switched out before they share it. Did they really share it? Guys, I wondered the same thing. When I watched this scene, there is no cut. It's a one or shot
就像在问，我的棒棒糖呢？哦天哪。这就是为什么他在和梅雷迪思的这场戏里有一根棒棒糖吗？是的。因为他的儿科医生顺道来看过他，给他检查了一下，还给了他一颗棒棒糖。嗯，这颗棒棒糖把我们带向了一个非常尴尬的结尾时刻。是的。那就是迈克尔在吮吸棒棒糖。他建议他们分享它。于是他把它递给了梅雷迪思，梅雷迪思接着把它塞进自己嘴里。然后她又把它递回给迈克尔，迈克尔说，不用了，不用了，我不用。好。好。好吧，我们收到了伊莱扎·贾维斯和娜塔莉·贝纳里的来信。请告诉我，迈克尔和梅雷迪思分享的那根棒棒糖在分享之前是调换过的。他们真的共用一根了吗？伙计们，我也想知道同样的事情。当我看到这一幕时，根本没有剪辑。这是一个一气呵成的镜头
of Steve taking the lollipop out of his mouth and handing it to Kate. So we asked Kate about it. We had to ask her about it. And she said they did not rinse it off. She also said Steve improvised that in the moment, and she just went with it. Yeah. And I think, I think that's why you see her pause a second. I think you are watching Kate, the person decide if she's going to do this. She's like, am I going to do this? But brilliant ending. Good for you, Kate. Way to, way to really go for it on the show. She said she got a thrill out of doing your own sort of stunts. So yeah, well, she's brave. And you know, there was a Dwight deleted talking head that I think would
史蒂夫把棒棒糖从嘴里拿出来递给凯特。所以我们问了凯特这件事。我们不得不问她。她说他们没有冲洗。她还说那是史蒂夫当时即兴发挥的，她只是顺着演下去了。是的。而且我想，我觉得这就是为什么你会看到她停顿了一秒钟。我想你正在看着凯特这个人，在决定她是否要这么做。她当时想，我要这么做吗？但结局太棒了。干得好，凯特。真有你的，在节目里真是豁出去了。她说她自己做这种特技觉得很刺激。所以，好吧，她很勇敢。你知道的，还有一个被删掉的德怀特的访谈镜头，我觉得会
have come after this where it's really, it kind of broke my heart where he talks about forgiveness and what it is to forgive someone and that he hopes that his friend will forgive him. Because if Meredith can forgive Michael for hitting her with a car, maybe his friend will be able to forgive him and he's hopeful. I know. It made me sad. Yeah. Well, I think that finishes out fun run. We did a fun run. Thank you guys so much for joining us for the Michael Scott DM S M P M C rabies awareness pro am fun run race for the cure. We'll be back next week. Thank you for listening to office ladies. Office ladies is produced by airwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer
在这之后出现，真的很，有点让我心碎，他在那里谈到了宽恕以及原谅某人意味着什么，并希望他的朋友能原谅他。因为如果梅雷迪思能原谅开车撞她的迈克尔，也许他的朋友就能原谅他，他抱有希望。我知道。这让我很伤心。好吧，我想这就结束了“快乐跑”。我们办了一场快乐跑。非常感谢大家加入我们参加由迈克尔·斯科特 D M S M P M C 狂犬病关怀职业业余超级趣味长跑治愈大赛。我们下周再见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Airwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗
and our associate producer is Ainsley bubukko. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of office ladies, go to Stitcher premium.com for a free one month trial of Stitcher premium use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制作人是Ainsley bubukko。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 Stitcher premium.com，使用优惠码 office 即可免费试用 Stitcher premium 一个月。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。